ALL RIGHT. WELCOME THE SUB
COMMITTEE WILL BE IN ORDER.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM FOR THE CONSULTANT. CALL
THE ROLL. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. UH
SENATOR PADILLA, SENATOR NE NILO
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A QUORUM. DOCKETED
ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION UNDER TWO
HEADINGS OF CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT AND DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
THAT'S COMPOSED OF ITEM ISSUES
THREE THROUGH 12. WILL TAKE
THOSE ITEMS FIRST. ON THE DOCKET
JUST FOR INFORMATION PURPOSES
FOR THOSE THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S HEARING TODAY
, AS WE WORK THROUGH
PRESENTATIONS AND COMMENT ON
EACH ISSUE FOR DISCUSSION, WE
WILL FOLLOW WITH WELCOMING
PUBLIC COMMENT, SO WE'LL TAKE AN
ISSUE BY ISSUE JUST TO KEEP IT
MORE BENEFICIAL AND CLEAR. I
WOULD MAKE RESPECTFULLY MAKE A
REQUEST OF THOSE THAT WISH TO
SPEAK UNDER PUBLIC COMMENT TO
EACH ISSUE, COME FORWARD AFTER
EACH ISSUE. IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT ISSUE IF
YOU HAVE A GENERAL COMMENTARY
OVERALL PERHAPS ABOUT HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, OR
ABOUT THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT. PLEASE WAIT UNTIL WE
TAKE SORT OF GENERAL COMMENT AT
THE END. IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE
A BROAD COMMENTARY AND NOT
ADDRESS THE SPECIFICS OF THE
ISSUE, AND THEN WE'LL BRING IT
TO THE SUBCOMITTEE, UH, AFTER
THE COMMENT ON EACH ISSUE, SO IT
JUST SORT OF MOVES US A LITTLE
BIT MORE EFFICIENCY EFFICIENTLY,
I THINK AND ALSO WITH A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY, AND IF YOU HAVEN'T
NOTICED, WE HAVE A GOOD AMOUNT
OF INTEREST JOINING US HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING ROOM AND IN
THE HALLWAY. SO WITH THAT, UH,
WE WILL PROCEED TO THE ITEMS FOR
DISCUSSION. FIRST THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT ISSUE THREE
REDUCTIONS IN ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATION AND CONCILIATION
ENHANCEMENTS. PRESENTERS COME
FORWARD. WELCOME. AND STATE YOUR
NAMES FOR THE RECORD AND PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD MORNING
. I'M JAMIE GILLETTE, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION WITH THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT. AND ADAM ROMERO, THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE EXECUTIVE
PROGRAMS DIVISION WITH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WE'RE HERE TO PRESENT
ONE ITEM AND BEFORE I LAUNCH
INTO THE END. I JUST LIKE TO
GIVE SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT. WE
ENFORCE CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS IN THE AREAS
OF EMPLOYMENT, HOUSING, PUBLIC
ACCOMMODATIONS AND BUSINESSES.
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES, HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND HATE VIOLENCE. èC R Dð
WORKS TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
RESPONSIBILITY IN A STATE AS
LARGE AND AS DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA WITH APPROXIMATELY
THREE 130 POSITIONS. EACH YEAR.
èC R Dð SERVES THE PUBLIC
INTEREST BY INVESTIGATING
THOUSANDS OF COMPLAINTS OF
DISCRIMINATION, CONCILIATING AND
SETTLING AS MANY OF THOSE CASES
AS POSSIBLE. AND PROSECUTING
HIGH IMPACT CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIONS
INTENDED TO BENEFIT LARGE
NUMBERS OF CALIFORNIANS. IN
ADDITION, AMONG OTHER
INITIATIVES TO ADVANCE CIVIL
RIGHTS, CONDUCTS EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR CIVIL
RIGHTS AND THEIR OBLIGATIONS.
AND RECENTLY LAUNCHED THE
CALIFORNIA VERSUS HATE RESOURCE
LINE AND NETWORK, WHICH PROVIDES
SERVICES TO THOSE TARGETED FOR
HATE. AS BACKGROUND IN THE FOR
THIS BUDGET ITEM IN THE 2022
BUDGET ACT ACT, THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A B èC P TITLED
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION AND
CONCILIATION, WHICH PROVIDED
THREE YEARS OF FUNDING TO èC R
Dð TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF TO
DECREASE THE WAIT TIME BETWEEN
WHEN A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
FILES AN INTAKE WITH WITH èC, R
Dð AND WHEN THEY ARE INTERVIEWED
BY OUR INVESTIGATORS TO INITIATE
OUR INVESTIGATION PROCESS. THE B
èC P FUNDING ALSO AIMED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
IS ABLE TO CONCILIATE AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE, SETTLE IN OUR
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION. SINCE JULY
. 1 2022 THE NUMBER OF INTAKES
FILED WITH OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN INCREASING. AND BECAUSE OF
THE RESOURCES THIS B èC P
PROVIDED OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
, WAIT TIMES FOR THE PUBLIC
DECREASED IN CONCILIATION
NUMBERS WENT UP. SO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR GILLETTE AND I ARE ABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. FOR THE PRESENTATION.
IF THAT CONCLUDES THAT I'LL
INVITE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE FIRST AND AGAIN WITH
RESPECT TO THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
ONLY IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE SUBCOMITTEE, PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD, AND I
WOULD ASK, GIVEN THE VOLUME OF
FOLKS INTERESTED THAT WE LIMIT
YOUR TIME TO ABOUT ONE MINUTE.
ANYONE WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
SUB-COMMITTEE ON THIS MATTER?
ALL RIGHT. I'LL BRING IT BACK
HERE TO THE SUB. FIRST AND
FOREMOST. THE COMMENTARY NOTES
THAT THERE'S A DIRECT
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE MODEST
INFUSION OF FUNDING THAT WAS
CHARACTERIZED AS TEMPORARY. UH,
AND THE IMPACT ON WAIT TIMES AND
ACCESS BY FOLKS WHO ARE SEEKING
A NUMBER OF AVENUES OF REDRESS.
HERE YOU LAY THAT OUT PRETTY
CLEARLY ABOUT HOW EFFECTIVE IT
HAS BEEN IN TERMS OF IMPACT, BUT
YET THEN CONCLUDE THAT WE
SHOULD, UH, YOU KNOW FOSTER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HERE, AND I
SEE AN INCONGRUITY THERE. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT? AND DO
YOU THINK YOU'D BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED? IF, IN
FACT WE HOLD BACK FUNDS. AND
INVITE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION.
AND THEN WE CAN TAKE THE SECOND.
THANK YOU. UM ANDREW MARCH,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO UM, AS
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT NOTED THIS WAS
TEMPORARY FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN THE 2022 BUDGET
UNDER A VERY DIFFERENT GENERAL
FUND SCENARIO, A VERY LARGE
SURPLUS. THE IDEA OF SORT OF
PROVIDING THE TEMPORARY FUNDING
WAS GIVEN THE PROJECTED OUTLOOK
AT THE TIME THAT, UM, THERE MAY
BE RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE TO
CONTINUE THIS TYPE OF WORK.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE GENERAL FUND
DEFICIT PROJECTED IN BUDGET YEAR
AND THE ONGOING GENERAL FUND
DEFICITS IT'S UNLIKE THAT THE
THAT THE GENERAL FUND WOULD BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING. SO THIS
IS WHY THIS PROPOSED AS A AS A
REDUCTION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, ALTHOUGH VERY DIFFICULT
DECISION TO BE MADE, HOWEVER,
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
STILL MAINTAINS A VERY ROBUST
BUDGET OF OVER $50 MILLION
GENERAL FUND, WHICH HAS
INCREASED BY OVER DOUBLE SINCE
2019 WHEN IT WAS AROUND 25
MILLION. SO READING BETWEEN THE
LINES. THANK YOU, UH, INTERNAL
EFFICIENCIES MAY BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THE TASK IN THE
INTERIM, GIVEN THE SCOPE OF THE
EXISTING THAT'S CERTAINLY A
POSSIBILITY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT WORKS EACH YEAR TO
DETERMINE UM YOU KNOW POTENTIAL
SAVINGS. HOWEVER IT'S DIFFICULT
TO PROJECT SAVINGS THAT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE BUDGET YEAR. BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WORK OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT IS NOT, UM SO
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THIS SORT
OF REDUCTION. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. CONCLUDES YOUR
PRESENTATION FROM DEPARTMENTAL
LEVEL ARTS L Ó HAVE ANY
COMMENTS? THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR, GINNY BELLA, WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS OFFICE.
NOTHING TO ADD, BUT HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
YOU MAY NEED. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMITTEE. SENATOR
SMALL CUEVAS YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
UM AND IT WAS, UH UH, I WAS GLAD
TO HEAR HOW THE INVESTMENT WAS
ABLE TO BE MEASURED AND WE COULD
SEE A REDUCTION IN THE WAIT TIME
AND RECEIVING SOME REMEDY. UM I
I'M I'M CURIOUS. IF YOUR
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAS A
BACKLOG OF CASES IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU ARE, UM, MOVING THE
ENFORCEMENT PHASES AND YOUR
CAPACITY TO BE CURRENT. WITH ALL
OF THOSE COMPLAINTS DOES THE
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAVE A
BACKLOG? JAMIE GILLETTE, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION. UM YES, WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE A BACKLOG. I
BELIEVE OUR CURRENT WAIT TIME
FOR CLIMATE RELATED
DISCRIMINATION CASES. UM, ON THE
TIME THAT YOU TAKE THE AND ON
OUR HOUSING AND CASES. AND SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THIS
REDUCTION WILL NOT HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON THE CURRENT STATUS IN
TERMS OF THE WAIT TIME AND THE
DELAYS. UM, I THINK IT'S LIKELY
THAT THIS REDUCTION WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT, INCREASING THE DELAYS.
THERE'S A LOT OF FACTORS THAT GO
INTO THE WAIT TIME. UM ONE OF
THOSE A NUMBER OF E. I NEVER
TASTES. THAT RIGHT? SO THAT'S
ONE BIG FACTOR IN. ADDITIONALLY,
UM WERE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
STREAMLINE OUR PROCESSES AND
MOVE RESOURCES AROUND TO CREATE
LESS OF AN IMPACT TO THE PUBLIC.
BUT I DO FORESEE THIS, UM, AT
LEAST SLOWING DOWN OUR ABILITY
TO DECREASE THE WAIT TIME AND I
AND I KNOW THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE QUITE A BIT, UM AND GOOD
WORK OF PROTECTING MORE AND MORE
CLASSES. UM UH AND SO IT'S NOT
JUST PROTECTING. I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TALKED
ABOUT A DOUBLING OF THE BUDGET,
BUT WE'VE ALSO INCREASED
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF FOLKS WHO
ARE PROTECTED IN TERMS OF, UM
FROM CANNABIS. UH TO, UM EQUAL
PAY AND OTHER OTHER IMPORTANT
POLICIES. SO HOW DO YOU HAVE? IS
THERE A PARTNERSHIPS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WORKS WITH TO SORT OF
HELP, ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE GOING
TO REDUCE AT SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
RATE? THE BUDGET ARE YOU LOOKING
TO PARTNERSHIPS TO HELP? SORT OF
, UM, ADDRESS WHAT WILL BE AN
INCREASE IN COMPLAINTS AND ALSO
THE CURRENT BACKLOG AND DELAY
THAT YOU HAVE. AND HOW DO YOU,
UM HOW DO YOU FACILITATE THOSE
KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS? WHERE
WHERE ARE THOSE KINDS OF
PARTNERSHIPS? AND WHAT IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT AND THOSE, UM,
ORGANIZATIONS OR OTHER AGENCIES
THAT YOU WORK WITH? SURE. AND WE
MEET QUARTERLY WITH DIFFERENT
ADVOCATE GROUPS AND DISCUSS ANY
ISSUES THAT THEY'RE HAVING WITH
THE COMPLAINT PROCESS. UM OR IF
THERE'S ANY AREAS THAT THEY FEEL
THE DEPARTMENT CAN IMPROVE UPON.
WE MEET QUARTERLY REQUESTS OR
FEEDBACK AND WORK THROUGH THEIR
FEEDBACK TO TRY TO IMPROVE OUR
PROCESSES. THE BEST WE CAN, UM
AND LIKE I SAID, WE LOOK, UM TO
WHERE WE CAN STREAMLINE OUR
PROCESSES WHERE WE COULD DO MORE
. PERHAPS INTAKE TRIAGE TO, UM
MAYBE NOT HAVE SOMEONE WAIT THE
FULL 90 DAYS FOR THEIR
APPOINTMENT. THERE'S SOMETHING
WE CAN REACH OUT TO THEM ABOUT
SOONER. AND THERE WAS ALSO A
MENTION THAT THERE WAS POTENTIAL
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. CAN YOU
SHARE WHERE THERE ARE OTHER
AREAS SPECIFICALLY THAT èC R?
Dð UM, HAS SAVED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. AND WHAT ARE THOSE
PROGRAMS WHERE YOU'RE SEEING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SAVINGS? THE
MAIN AREA IS IN THE VACANCIES IN
IN AT THE DEPARTMENT IN OUR, UH
FUNDED POSITIONS. I DID. AND
WHAT IS THE VACANCY RATE RIGHT
NOW? WITHIN èC, R Dð, UH,
CURRENTLY IT'S AROUND, UH, 12 OR
13% FOR THE DEPARTMENT. IN LINE
WITH COMPARABLE STATE AGENCIES.
WELL, I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. I AM CONFUSED AS
TO HOW REDUCING THE BUDGET
KNOWING THAT IT WILL IMPACT
DELAYS, KNOWING IT WILL IMPACT
BACKLOG KNOWING THAT IT UM COMES
AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS. I'M NOT SURE HOW
THIS FORMULA WORKS, I. I
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIPS. UM
BUT WE KNOW SO MANY OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES ARE
ALSO, UM OVERBURDENED AND
UNDERSTAFFED. AND SO, UM, II, I
WILL CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO WHAT
THE STRATEGIES WILL BE. BUT I AM
NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW REDUCING
YOUR FUNDING AT A TIME WHEN IT
SEEMS THE DEPARTMENT UH NEEDS TO
BE RAMPING UP AND HAVE MORE
CAPACITY TO DO THE WORK THAT
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT, SO THANK
YOU FOR THE INFORMATION. AND OUR
SENATOR ANILLO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. MY COMMENT. UM,
DOESN'T UH ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY, UM, THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN IN JANUARY DOES NOT
MEET THE BUDGET GAP THAT WE KNOW
NOW THAT WE HAVE. I REALIZE
THERE'S SOME DIFFERENCES IN
NUMBERS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE LAO, ALTHOUGH,
AS I'VE SAID BEFORE. I'M
INCLINED TO UM HAVE MORE TRUST
IN THE ASSESSMENT OF THE BUDGET
ADVISOR THAN THE BUDGET WRITER
AND NÓ OFFENSE, BUT THERE'S
DIFFERENCE IN PRESSURES THERE
AND SO WE HAVE A LARGER DEFICIT
TO PLUG. NOW THAN WE DID IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN JANUARY.
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
COME UP WITH MANY MORE
REDUCTIONS IN THE BUDGET. FROM
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY LOOKING AT
BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE. AND EVERY
REDUCTION THAT IS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED. THAT WE REJECT. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CUT SOMETHING
ELSE. AND THE BUDGET THAT'S
ADOPTED IN JUNE. IS PROBABLY
GOING TO HAVE DETAILS. TO
IRRITATE. EVERYBODY. I'M SORRY,
BUT THAT IS THE REALITY OF THE
NATURE OF THE BUDGET HOLE
CURRENTLY THAT WE HAVE TO PLUG.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THIS ITEM WILL
BE HELD OPEN. WE WILL THEN MOVE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS. UM AT
TOP LINE, WE ISSUE FOUR IS, UH,
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED HOUSING
SPENDING REDUCTION IN CONTEXT.
TYPICALLY AS YOU KNOW, WE'VE
GOTTEN IN THE HABIT OF SORT OF
DIRECTLY BEING RESPONSIVE TO
INDIVIDUAL ITEMS PROFFERED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND OFTEN WE
MISS THE OPPORTUNITY TO MORE
BROADLY CONTEXTUALIZE THAT
CONVERSATION, UH WHICH I THINK
IS MUCH MORE COMPLETE AND CLEAR.
AND SO TO THAT WE HAVE ASKED THE
LAO TO PRESENT WITH RESPECT TO
THAT HERE TODAY. SO WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR, GINNY BELLA
, WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, AND WE WERE ASKED TODAY
TO PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE REDUCTIONS PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S 2425 BUDGET FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND TALK A
BIT ABOUT HOW THOSE REDUCTIONS
ARE NESTED WITHIN THE BROADER
STATE. UH, FUNDING FOR HOUSING.
SO AS YOU KNOW, OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS, THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETIONARY STATE
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO HÌ èC Dð
FOR HOUSING PROGRAMS. UH, BUT
GIVEN THE BUDGET CONSTRAINTS
THAT SENATOR NILO JUST LAID OUT
AND THE GOVERNOR'S 2425 BUDGET,
THERE ARE ABOUT 1.2 BILLION IN
REDUCTIONS ACROSS SEVEN MAJOR
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THOSE REDUCTIONS
ARE PRIMARILY TO, UH, PROGRAMS
THAT RECEIVED NEW, UH,
DISCRETIONARY TEMPORARY FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS. UH, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE REDUCTION FOR
THE HOUSING NAVIGATOR PROGRAM,
WHICH IS AN ONGOING PROGRAM THAT
THE REDUCTION WOULD BE AN
ONGOING REDUCTION, SO THIS
REALLY ACCELERATES THE END OF
THE STATE FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM AND REALLY REDUCES THE
OVERALL AUGMENTATION THAT IS
PROVIDED. WE WILL WALK THROUGH
EACH OF THOSE REDUCTIONS IN IN
DETAIL AS WE GO THROUGH, SO WE
WON'T TALK ABOUT EACH ONE
SPECIFICALLY, BUT AT A HIGH
LEVEL. EACH OF THE REDUCTIONS IS
A AROUND A COUPLE 100 MILLION,
ADDING UP AGAIN TO THAT 1.2
BILLION TOTAL AGAIN, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE HOUSING
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM, WHICH IS JUST
A SMALLER PROGRAM, SO IT
NECESSARILY SMALLER REDUCTION IS
BEING PROPOSED. UH IN TERMS OF
HOW THE FUNDING REALLY FITS
WITHIN THE BROADER STATE FUNDING
FOR HOUSING. MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR
REDUCTION HAVE HISTORICALLY
RECEIVED BOND FUNDING FOR THEIR
ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
INDEPENDENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS. THAT BOND THAT BOND
FUNDING IS WINDING DOWN. SO
ALONG WITH THE EXPIRATION OF THE
GENERAL FUND, AND THAT BOND
FUNDING, SOME OF THE FUNDING FOR
THESE PROGRAMS WILL WILL END
ONCE THAT THAT MONEY IS GONE,
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHICH ONES
OF THOSE SPECIFICALLY AS WE GO.
THE AGENDA TODAY. ADDITIONALLY
THE STATE ANNUALLY PROVIDES
ABOUT 120 MILLION ANNUALLY FOR
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT. AND IN RECENT YEARS, UH,
THE STATE HAS BEEN SUPPLEMENTING
THAT TEMPORARILY ON A ONE TIME
BASIS WITH A AN ADDITIONAL 500
MILLION AND THAT THAT IS ALSO
EXPIRING. ALTHOUGH THOSE FUNDING
STREAMS MAY BE WINDING DOWN,
THERE ARE SOME ONGOING STATE
FUNDING STREAMS THAT CONTINUE TO
BE AVAILABLE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR HOUSING, AND THAT
INCLUDES REVENUES FROM S¼ B TWO
AND ALSO FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND, WHICH FUNDS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. UH,
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
SO TO THE ANSWER THE OTHER
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA ABOUT
HOW TO ASSESS THESE REDUCTIONS.
AND HOW TO THINK ABOUT
ALTERNATIVES. UH, AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT ALREADY TODAY, THE
GIVEN THE BUDGET PROBLEM YOU ARE
GOING TO BE FACED WITH DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THIS YEAR. IT'S GOING
TO REQUIRE A COMBINATION OF
REDUCTIONS. REVENUE INCREASES,
UM, USING SOME OF THE RESERVES
FUND SHIFTS ALL THE TOOLS AND
THE TOOLKIT REALLY. AND WE SEE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS ONE
OPTION FOR YOU TO CONSIDER. OF
COURSE, THE LEGISLATURE'S
ULTIMATE BUDGET MAY REFLECT
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES. AND SO WE
THINK YOUR TIME TODAY SHOULD BE
SPENT REALLY HEARING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE BOTH THE
RATIONALE FOR THE REDUCTIONS
THEY'RE PUTTING BEFORE YOU BUT
ALSO HEARING FROM THEM WHETHER
THERE ARE OTHER AREAS. OTHER
GENERAL FUND WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS THAT THE GOVERNOR DID
NOT PROPOSE TO REDUCE IN AREAS
THAT YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER.
SO YOU HAVE THE WHOLE PACKAGE IN
FRONT OF YOU OF YOUR OPTIONS. ON
THAT NOTE. WE ACTUALLY JUST
RELEASED A REPORT WHERE WE TRIED
TO LOOK STATEWIDE AT ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
PRIOR BUDGETS THAT MAYBE HASN'T
GONE OUT YET HASN'T BEEN FULLY
SPENT AS SORT OF SHOWING YOU THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS BEFORE YOU NOT
JUST IN, UM HÌ èC Dð, BUT
ACROSS THE STATE BUDGET, AND WE
DID A PRELIMINARY I PRE
PRELIMINARILY IDENTIFIES ABOUT
16 BILLION IN FUNDING THERE, SO
THAT COULD BE THINGS THAT YOU
COULD CONSIDER GOING FORWARD.
UM, AND WITH THAT, I WILL
CONCLUDE MY OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU. WE WILL LOOK TO ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE. THEN I'LL ASK FOR
COMMENT FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WANT TO COMMENT
BROADLY ON CONTEXT. UH, MATT
SCHULER, UH, WITH THE DEPARTMENT
? UH, I'M THE ADMINISTRATIVE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. UH, DON'T HAVE
ANY COMMENTS SPECIFICALLY ON
THIS TIME IN TERMS OF ADDRESS
YOURSELF SPECIFICALLY ISSUE TO
ISSUE AS WE TALKED ABOUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS, ALL RIGHT?
COULDN'T PERSUADE YOU. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S ASK FOR, UH, ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO COMMENT, UH, SORT
OF BROADLY AGAIN, NOT ISSUE OR
PROGRAM SPECIFIC. PLEASE COME TO
THE MIC. STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD AND TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE. PLEASE
WELCOME MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JULIE SNYDER, REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF AREA GOVERNMENTS
AND THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. WE
ARE THE PARENT AGENCIES TO THE
BAY AREA HOUSING FINANCE
AUTHORITY, AND YOU ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT GENERALLY, I'LL TALK
LATER ABOUT THE PROGRAM AND SOME
OF THE SPECIFICALLY, UH,
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. BUT WHY DON'T
WE SHARE YESTERDAY WE MET WITH A
FORMER BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIR.
THAT THE PERSON WHO WILL REMAIN
NAMELESS POINTED OUT THAT
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS AND CLIMATE PROGRAMS
ARE CONTINUALLY ON THE CHOPPING
BLOCK BECAUSE THEIR GENERAL
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATIONS HAVE
BEEN ON QUOTE ONE TIME BASIS
WHEN THE STATE HAS EXTRA FUNDS.
THEREFORE THEY'RE EASIER QUOTE
UNQUOTE TO CUT THAN PERMANENT
PROGRAMS, BUT FRANKLY, THAT'S
EXACTLY THE PROBLEM. HOUSING
WHICH IS FOUNDATIONAL TO EVERY
SINGLE PERSON'S LIFE. IT'S STILL
CONSIDERED SOMETHING THE STATE
ONLY FUNDS WHEN IT HAS EXTRA
MONEY. BUT THE RELENTLESS GAP
BETWEEN RENTS AND HOME PRICES
AND INCOMES IN THE STATE MEANS
THAT IT'S TIME TO LOOK AT
FINDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. THE SHORTAGE THAT
WAS DECADES IN THE MAKING IS
GOING TO TAKE SUSTAINED
INVESTMENT TO DIG OUR WAY OUT OF
THAT HOLE AND THE LONGER THE
STATE DELAYS IN MAKING THESE
LONG TERM COMMITMENTS, INCLUDING
TO REPLACE THE BILLION DOLLARS
THERE WAS A BILLION DOLLARS IN
REDEVELOPMENT HOUSING FUNDS THAT
WERE SWEPT INTO THE GENERAL FUND
IN 2012 AND HAVE NEVER BEEN
REPLACED. THE LONGER IT TAKES TO
FILL THAT GAP, THE MORE
EXPENSIVE IT'S GOING TO BE NOT
ONLY IN DOLLARS BECAUSE WE KNOW
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE GOING UP
RAPIDLY, BUT ALSO IN LIVES. SO
YOU CAN START TODAY BY REJECTING
ALL OF THE CUTS AND STARTING TO
THINK ABOUT HOUSING FUNDING IN A
DIFFERENT WAY, MAKING IT A
PERMANENT PRIORITY IN THE STATE
BUDGET SO THAT WE CAN JUST AS
RELENTLESSLY MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS THE DAY THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS AN AFFORDABLE
PLACE TO LIVE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP,
AND I ADD A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT TO THE ELOQUENT STAFF
RIGHT UP. I DON'T NEED TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
181,000 PEOPLE FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS WHO REMAIN ON HOUSE
EVERY NIGHT OR THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WHO ARE
PAYING WAY MORE THAN THEY CAN
AFFORD IN RENT, AND WE KNOW THAT
THE SOLUTION TO BOTH IS CREATING
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. UM WE,
YOU KNOW, WE ESTIMATED THAT A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO BUILD 1.2 MILLION
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING OVER
10 YEARS OR 120,000 A YEAR. AT
THE PEAK OF OUR PRODUCTION TWO
YEARS AGO, AND WE HAD ACCESS TO
STATE AND LOCAL BOND FUNDS. WE
WERE AT 20,000 SO 1/6 OF THE
TOTAL. THAT NUMBER IS NOW
DECLINING FAST BECAUSE OF THE
COMBINATION OF THE BONDS RUNNING
OUT OF BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET. WHEN YOU LOOK AT BOTH
THE CLAWBACKS AND THE, UM KIND
OF NOT RENEWING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE STATE CREDITS,
AND SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS
WOULD REDUCE THAT PRODUCTION BY
ANOTHER 6400 UNITS. AND
REMEMBER, THOSE ARE HOMES THAT
ARE AFFORDABLE FOR EACH OF 55
YEARS, SO OVER THE LONG TERM
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE USE THOSE
STATE FUNDS TO FILL GAPS IN IN
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ALLOW US TO
ACCESS FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS. SO LOSING
THAT 1.6 BILLION IN WE ACTUALLY
LOSE AN ADDITIONAL 1.6 BILLION
IN FEDERAL RESOURCES BY NOT
PROVIDING THAT GAP FUNDING. SO
WE'RE LEAVING FEDERAL RESOURCES
ON THE TABLE. UM YOU KNOW WHAT?
ULTIMATELY WE'LL SPEAK TO THE
INDIVIDUAL ITEMS. WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE THE LEGISLATURE RESTORE
ALL OF THE HOUSING MONEY, BUT
OUR PRIORITIES ARE FOR THE STATE
ON THE PRODUCTION SIDE FOR THE
STATE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX.
CREDITS FOR 2025 ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO FUND THE MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM, WHICH IS THE
MOST GENERAL THAT CAN SERVE ALL
NEEDS AND ON THE HOMELESSNESS
SIDE FOR THE HAP PROGRAM AS WELL
SO AND JUST, UH TO THE TAX
CREDITS. THEY ACTUALLY DON'T
COUNT AGAINST THIS BUDGET. THEY
ARE THEY ARE SCORED IN A WAY
THAT THEY COME. THEY HAVE AN
IMPACT 2 TO 6 YEARS FROM NOW,
AND SO, UH, AND THEN, LASTLY,
THIS IS THIS BUDGET IS THE YEAR
THAT WILL BRIDGE US TO HOPEFULLY
HAVING A HOUSING BOND ON THE
BALLOT WHERE WE CAN FUND SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS IN A DIFFERENT
MANNER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, AND THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. MY NAME IS
NATALIE SPIVAK AND I'M WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA, A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON ENDING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISES,
WITH THESE CRISES GOING GROWING
WORSE, AND THE BOND FUNDING FROM
2018 RUNNING OUT AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR. THIS ISN'T THE TIME
FOR THESE MASSIVE CUTS TO THE
STATE'S CRITICAL PRODUCTION
PROGRAMS. AND ALTHOUGH THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR PERMITTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE FAVORABLE, THANKS TO
CRITICAL LAWS THAT YOU ALL HAVE
PLAYED A ROLE IN PASSING IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. STATE FUNDING FOR
STATE FUNDING THAT MAKES THESE
PROGRAMS AND DEVELOPMENTS
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE HASN'T KEPT
UP. UM SO, ADDITIONALLY, THE
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM THAT
MARK MENTIONED THE STATE'S
FLAGSHIP AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION PROGRAM IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AT A RATE OF 10
TO 1, WHICH REPRESENTS 15,000
PERMITTED SHOVEL READY,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS THAT
ONLY NEED STATE FUNDING TO BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION WHEN PROJECTS
LANGUISH IN DEVELOPERS,
PIPELINES, DEVELOPMENT BECOMES
MORE EXPENSIVE AND HOUSING,
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
CONTINUE TO RISE. ADDITIONALLY
CUTTING THE STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WILL
PREVENT THE STATE FROM DRAWING
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDING, LEAVING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION ON
THE TABLE. INVESTING IN
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO TRANSFORM
THE LIVES OF MILLIONS OF LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS FACING
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSTABILITY. WE ARE DUE TO
RESTORE THESE CUTS TO THESE
CRITICAL PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN, JUST A
FRIENDLY REMINDER. THE COM THE
SUB COMMITTEE WELCOMES
EVERYONE'S TESTIMONY NOW AND ON
EACH ITEM, BUT PLEASE RESTRICT
YOUR COMMENTS TO ABOUT A MINUTE,
OK? THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
KI¾M LARES, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH,
AND I WOULD JUST SAY GLOBALLY,
UM, ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MANY
OF THE PEOPLE AROUND. UM WE NEED
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
DEVELOPMENT. BUT I'D ASK YOU TO
THINK ABOUT ONE OF OUR NEEDS FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
THOSE 18 TO 25 TRANSITION. YOU
WHO STRUGGLE AND HAVE LACK OF
CREDIT, LACK OF RENTAL HISTORIES
, JUST GIVEN THEIR AGES AND HOW
DO WE THINK ABOUT PREVENTING
THEM FROM BECOMING OUR GROWING
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS POPULATION
IF WE AREN'T SUPPORTING THEM AND
MOVING AS FAR UPSTREAM AS
POSSIBLE, BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED, UNDERCOUNTED
IN THE HOMELESS COUNTS AND SO
GLOBALLY ASKING YOU TO THINK
ABOUT WHERE DO YOU FIT INTO
CREATING HOUSING FOR THEM?
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS
DON'T NECESSARILY WORK THAT WELL
IN CREATING HOUSING FOR OUR
YOUTH AND WORKING WITH THOSE,
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO'VE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MELISSA
WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AND WE WOULD
JUST STRONGLY URGE FOR THE
RESTORATION OF INVESTMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS AND
IN PARTICULAR THE $500 MILLION
FOR THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AMY
HINDS. SHE QUIT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK,
THE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK
AND ITS 52 MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS
REGRETTED LEARNING OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CUT 400
OR 248 MILLION OF THE 485
MILLION. BUDGET 51% FROM THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A TOUGH
BUDGET OUTLOOK, BUT WE IMPLORE
YOU ALL TO RECONSIDER CUTTING
HALF OF THE PHIPS FUNDING, WHICH
WILL UNDERMINE THE PROGRAM AT
THIS CRITICAL JUNCTURE. THE NEED
FOR THIS PROGRAM IS TOO GREAT
AND BOTH HÌ èC Dð AND OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE SUNK TOO MANY
RESOURCES INTO THIS PIONEERING
HOUSING STRATEGY TO HOBBLE IT.
NOW WE URGE YOUR
RECONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS RAN
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND ITS
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION, ONE
OF THE LARGEST, UM LOW INCOME
HOUSING PROVIDERS IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES, WITH MORE THAN 1500
UNITS NOW FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME, UM BAD
TIME TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY GOING TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, ESPECIALLY WITH A
NUMBER OF UNHOUSED PEOPLE GOING
UP, UM, BUT IF CUTS ARE
INEVITABLE, WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO MORE WITH
ADAPTIVE REUSE OF EXISTING
BUILDINGS. IN $120,000, A UNIT
AS OPPOSED TO 56 $700,000 A UNIT
FOR GROUND UP CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
TAMIKA LÀ. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST. AND I'M HERE TODAY,
UM, ON BEHALF OF OUR STATEWIDE
COALITION AND ALL THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUSTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE NOT CUT THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION HOUSING
PREVENTION PROGRAM FUNDING
ANYMORE THAN HAS ALREADY BEEN
PROPOSED. YOU KNOW, COVID FOLKS
ARE STILL, UM, TRYING TO RECOVER
, FOLKS. THEY'RE STILL FOLKS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO ON OUR
STREETS YOU NEIGHBORS OF AND
YOUR STAFF. MEMBERS WHO ARE
STILL TRYING TO RECOVER, AND WE
KNOW THAT AS OF JANUARY. 2024
THERE ARE STILL ABOUT 235,001 TO
25 UNIT BUILDINGS THAT ARE AT
RISK, AND THOSE ARE FAMILIES.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT END UP ON
THE STREETS. AND SO WE URGE YOU
TODAY TO KEEP AS MUCH FUNDING IN
THE FIT PROGRAM AS POSSIBLE. I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S INPUT. I
JUST WANT TO REMIND THE AUDIENCE
. PERHAPS I DIDN'T ARTICULATE IT
AS CLEARLY AS I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN, BECAUSE THE NOISE IN THE
HALLWAY MADE IT DIFFICULT FOR
EVERYONE. YOU KNOW, WE'RE ASKING
FOR YOUR INPUT ON THE
CONVERSATION. COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERING NOW WHICH IS THE
CONTEXTUAL CONVERSATION OF THE
PRESENTATION. THE LAO GAVE NOT
TO COME UP AND ASK FOR NOT TO
CUT OR TO, YOU KNOW TO ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF SPECIFIC ISSUES OR
PROGRAMS. CONVERSATION IS ABOUT
WHAT IS THE METHODOLOGY WE
UTILIZED HERE. WHAT WERE
ALTERNATIVES, ENCOURAGING THE
BROADER UNDERSTANDING? I WANTED
TO GIVE EVERYBODY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE PART OF THAT CONVERSATION,
NOT JUST THE COMMITTEE, BUT
PERHAPS WE WILL NOT REPEAT THAT
AGAIN BECAUSE FOLKS ARE JUST
USING IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TWICE TO THE SAME ISSUE
AND NOT GONNA ALLOW THAT EITHER.
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR. I WANT
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC AS TO
THIS DISCUSSION, NOT TO A
SPECIFIC ISSUE OR PROGRAM THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP IN MORE
DETAIL. I APOLOGIZE IF I DID NOT
MAKE THAT CLEAR, AND I DO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION
IF THERE IS NOT ANY MORE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ON THIS ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR DISCUSSION WILL
BRING IT BACK. ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSES OR COMMENTS
YOU WANT TO MAKE TO THIS BROAD
DISCUSSION? WE'LL TAKE THEM NOW
AND THEN I'M GOING TO COME TO
THE SUBCOMITTEE. MR CHAIR
MEMBERS MAT SCHULER AGAIN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. I WOULD DEFER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
TALK ABOUT THE RATIONALE BEHIND
THE REDUCTIONS THAT WERE MADE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THEN
I WOULD BE YOU KNOW, MORE THAN
PLEASED TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
THAT YOU HAD WITH RESPECT TO ANY
REMAINING FUNDING TO DELVE INTO
THAT DISCUSSION. COMMENT. AND
MARCH. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UM
JUST TO SPEAK BROADLY. UM SINCE
2019 THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HAVE PROVIDED $5.2
BILLION APPROXIMATELY GENERAL
FUND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS, UM IT DESPITE THE
REDUCTIONS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT LEAVES
AROUND $4 BILLION OF GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENTS OVER THE LAST 4
TO 5 YEARS, UM GENERALLY
SPEAKING FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE
REDUCTIONS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THERE ARE PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDING THAT HADN'T ALREADY BEEN
ISSUED AND A NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY. SO THESE AREN'T
UM, FUNDS THAT GENERALLY WERE
ACCEPTING AWARDS OR, OR UM,
ALTHOUGH THEY MAY HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S, UH
NÓ F CALENDAR NOTICE OF FUNDING
ABILITY, CALENDAR ALERTING
PEOPLE THAT IN THE FUTURE, THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
THERE WEREN'T ACTIVELY ACCEPTING
AWARDS FOR THESE SO WE VIEWED IT
AS AN, UM AS DIFFICULT DECISIONS
TO MAKE. BUT HOWEVER, TRYING NOT
TO DISRUPT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY,
ALTHOUGH WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE WILL BE FEWER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS CREATED GIVEN THE
LACK OF FUNDING, HOWEVER, WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO VERIFY SOME OF THE
NUMBERS PRESENTED BY
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE THERE MAY
BE OTHER FUNDING THAT'S ABLE TO
BE UTILIZED THAT WASN'T UTILIZED
IN THE PAST, WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH LOCAL FUNDS THAT MAYBE,
UH, COMING ONLINE OR
REPRIORITIZATION OF EXISTING
ONGOING FUNDING, SUCH AS THE
BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS TRUST
FUND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL, UM FOR
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
CAN YOU DIG A LITTLE DEEPER
EITHER FROM THE PROGRAMMATIC
DRIVER OR THE FINAL CUT FOLKS
OVER HERE AT THE A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER ABOUT THE RATIONALE
EMPLOYED AND WHAT ALTERNATIVES.
WE CONSIDER PROGRAMMATICALLY. IN
TERMS OF HOW WE ASSESS THE
RELATIVE VALUE. I MEAN, THEY ALL
HAVE VALUE. BUT WE HAVE TO DO
THAT SORT OF RELATIVE ASSESSMENT
IN TERMS OF CONSTRAINED REVENUE,
RIGHT. SO HOW DID YOU ARRIVE AT
THIS IDENTIFICATION OF THESE
PARTICULAR CUTS AND WHAT WERE
ALTERNATIVES, IF ANY, THAT WERE
DISCUSSED? ANDREWS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AGAIN. SO, UM I. I
WOULDN'T SAY THAT THESE
REDUCTIONS NECESSARILY SPEAK TO
THE EFFICACY OR EFFICIENCY OF
ANY PARTICULAR PROGRAMS. UM THEY
ARE DIFFICULT CHOICES THAT WERE
MADE TO HELP BALANCE THE BUDGET.
UM SO GIVEN THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING THAT HADN'T
BEEN NOTICED, AND A NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY, THERE WAS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SORT OF
REBALANCE IT. OVERALL GENERAL
FUND STRATEGY. I THINK THE L Ó
AND OTHERS HAVE NOTED THAT DUE
TO THE DELAYED TAX RECEIPTS LAST
YEAR, WE MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN A
DIFFERENT SITUATION WHERE WE
WERE SORT OF TALKING ABOUT THIS
LAST YEAR. HOWEVER GIVEN THE
DELAY, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT
NOW. SO UM, HINDSIGHT'S 2020. IF
WE WERE ABLE TO GO BACK IN TIME,
WE MAY HAVE REPRIORITIZED SOME
OF THESE INVESTMENTS, GIVEN THE
GIVEN THE INFORMATION THAT WE
KNOW NOW. BRING IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SUB COMMITTEE
OR THEIR QUESTIONS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE, SENATOR SMALL
CUEVAS I AM APPRECIATING THE
CONVERSATION AND THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BECAUSE YOU KNOW? THIS
IS A VERY, VERY, VERY, VERY HARD
TIME. UM FOR ALL OF US AND IN MY
DISTRICT WHERE WE HAVE SUCH A
VISIBLE AND VISCERAL DAILY
ENCOUNTER WITH HUMAN SUFFERING
ON OUR STREETS. THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
COMMITMENTS TO ADDRESS UM
WHETHER IT IS UM, HAVING A
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION COME AND
POINT OUT CALIFORNIA'S UM CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, YOU KNOW, AND
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO TRY TO
JUST MAKE SURE FAMILIES IN
PARTICULARLY MANY OF THEM
WORKING FULL TIME BUT STILL
CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING HAVE HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED. I I AM JUST
WANTING TO SPEAK THE VERY, VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE HERE. UM, I GUESS
IN TERMS OF THE PROPOSED CUTS, A
LOT OF THESE CUTS AND I, I GUESS
I'M DIRECTING THIS TO A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THESE ARE
FUNDS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN USED OR
HAVE NOT BEEN. RELEASE PRIMARILY
, AND THESE ARE ALSO FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN UTILIZED IN THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE RELYING ON CAN
YOU CLARIFY IN TERMS OF THESE
SORT OF ACROSS THE BOARD VERY
DIVERSE SETS OF HOUSING. UM,
FUNDING POTS. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THESE RECOMMENDED CUTS ARE
COMING FROM MONIES THAT ARE NOT
RELIED ON RIGHT NOW, AND WHAT
PERCENT ARE COMING FROM PROGRAMS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY RELYING ON
THESE DOLLARS TO COME DOWN? UM,
IN THE BUDGET. I WANT TO GET A
REAL SENSE OF THAT TO ME. THAT
MAKES A LOT OF DIFFERENCE. WHERE
ARE YOU KNOW? WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THIS IS EBBS AND
FLOW, RIGHT? AND SO WE KNOW THAT
ONCE DOLLARS ARE RELEASED AND
FOLKS AND COMMUNITIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE RELYING ON THEM. WE
DO HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE
SURE PARTICULARLY AROUND
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE PROGRESS THAT WE
MUST MAKE. BUT THERE'S ALSO THE
REALITY THAT SOME OF THESE
DOLLARS HAVE NOT BEEN USED. THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN LET GO YET, AND WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF AN
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY TO DEAL
WITH OUR FISCAL CHALLENGE. CAN
YOU GIVE ME A SENSE OF WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE CUTS? IF IT'S A
IF IT'S A PIE CHART, LIKE HOW
MUCH OF IT IS HOW MUCH OF IT IS
MONEY THAT'S IN PLAY. YEAH SO,
UM, SO MAYBE BREAK IT UP INTO
TWO DIFFERENT BUCKETS. SO
THERE'S ÁP APPROXIMATELY ABOUT
900 MILLION. UM THAT'S FOR
FUNDING. THAT WOULD, UM, THAT
WAS COMMITTED TO COME OUT IN
FUTURE YEARS. UM UM, FOR SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE'LL GET TO,
UM AS WE GO DOWN THE REDUCTION
SORT OF LIST. AND THEN FUNDING
THAT HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN
BUDGETED. BUT IT HADN'T BEEN
AWARDED. YET THE DEPARTMENT
WASN'T ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS
FOR IT. UM SO IT'D BE, UM, IT'D
BE DIFFICULT TO SAY WHETHER
COMMUNITIES WERE RELYING ON THAT
FUNDING BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
HASN'T RECEIVED APPLICATIONS FOR
IT. ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY BUDGETED FUNDING, BUT
SO IT'S DIFFICULT TO SORT OF
COMMENT SPECIFICALLY ON WHAT
COMMUNITIES WERE RELYING ON
BECAUSE WE WEREN'T ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN
EVALUATING THOSE APPLICATIONS
FOR THAT FUNDING, BUT IT WASN'T
AND THEN THERE IS ANOTHER.
THERE'S ANOTHER BUCKET OF
FUNDING THAT HAD BEEN, UM UM,
NOTICED, AND I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND WE'LL GET
TO THIS PROGRAM. UM, THE
REGIONAL EARLY ACTION PLANNING
PROGRAM, UM, WHERE THAT FUNDING
HAD BEEN AWARDED, BUT NOT ALL
UTILIZED TO DATE. UM, AND YOU
MENTIONED IT IMPACT. I JUST IN
PARTICULAR. SOMETHING LIKE
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS. MY
SENTENCE IS A STEP THREE
CRITERIA. IN TERMS OF HOW YOU
MEASURING WHAT IS THE DIRECT
IMPACT? IS THERE SOME SORT OF
THE VALUE TO, UM, THAT THAT
APPARENTLY IS USING TO REALLY UM
WHAT THE MEASURED IMPACT WILL BE
IF WE CUT THESE FUNDS,
PARTICULARLY ON INDIVIDUALS, IS
THAT IS THERE A METRICS FOR
THAT? IS THAT DATA AVAILABLE TO
US AS LEGISLATORS TO SEE THAT
DATA? THESE ARE REALLY HARD
DECISIONS. UM THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING AND
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND AND BE ABLE
TO NOT JUST MEASURE THE NUMBERS
RIGHT? BUT TO MEASURE THE IMPACT
, WHICH HELPS WITH OUR DECISION
MAKING, AND SO, UM YOU KNOW
THERE ARE ON ISSUES LIKE THIS,
OFTENTIMES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
THERE ARE TOOLS TO REALLY LOOK
AT THE IMPACT AND HOW WE
MITIGATE CUTS AND MAKE CHOICES
WAY. WAIT ON THAT. I JUST I'M
CURIOUS WHAT YOU'RE USING, AND
IS THAT METRICS AVAILABLE TO US
TO REVIEW AND SEE IN REAL TIME,
SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE AN,
UM, AN ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY
UNITS WOULD NOT BE CREATED
ABSENT THIS FUNDING, AS NOTED BY
SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS, THERE
IS AN ESTIMATE. OF APPROXIMATELY
6400 UNITS WOULD NOT BE CREATED.
IF THIS FUNDING WAS NOT PUT
FORWARD. IT IS DIFFICULT FOR US
TO DETERMINE THAT BECAUSE IT IT
WOULD BE A WORD FUNDING ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS, AND
THE DEPARTMENT CAN DEFINITELY
SPEAK TO THIS AND SO THE COST
FOR EACH FOR EACH PROJECT MAY
VARY. UM SO, YOU KNOW, COMING TO
SORT OF AN ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY
UNITS ARE BEING FOREGONE BY
REDUCING THIS WOULD BE DIFFICULT
TO DETERMINE. HOWEVER, WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE WOULD BE FEWER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS CREATED
, ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
COME TO A YOU KNOW AN IMMEDIATE
NUMBER, UM, BECAUSE THERE MAY BE
OTHER FUNDING THAT COMES ONLINE
EITHER THROUGH, YOU KNOW, THERE
MAY BE PHILANTHROPY OR OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL, EITHER, WHETHER IT'S A
LOCAL BOND OR OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY
THAT IT'S A ZERO SUM GAME RIGHT
NOW, BUT THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
OTHER FUNDING THAT WOULD COME IN
BEHIND THIS FUNDING AND SUPPLANT
IT. I FEEL LIKE FOR THE, UH, FOR
OUR AGENCIES THAT THAT I'M
RELYING ON YOU ALL TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE IMPACTS ARE
I. I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING. I UNDERSTAND THE SORT
OF HOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM
A SPREADSHEET AND ACCOUNTING
PERSPECTIVE. BUT THE HUMAN
PERSPECTIVE IS WHAT I'M
INTERESTED IN. IF WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE CUTS, WE NEED TO KNOW HOW
MANY UNITS WE NEED TO KNOW WHERE
WE KNOW WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND I, YOU KNOW, I, UH, MR
CHAIR. I HOPE THAT WE WILL GET
MORE DETAIL. INFORMATION ON THAT
, UM, PARTICULARLY AROUND
HOMELESSNESS. I MEAN, WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT AND WHEN FOLKS ARE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST THAT IS A
JOB KILLER. THAT MEANS THEY'RE
NOT WORKING. THAT MEANS THEY'RE
NOT EARNING AN INCOME. THAT
MEANS THEY'RE NOT IN THE ECONOMY
AND THAT CREATES ANOTHER CRISIS.
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE ON
HOMELESSNESS. THESE THINGS ARE
ARE INTEGRATED. THEY ARE
INTERSECTIONAL, AND WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE HUMAN IMPACT THE
MATERIAL IMPACT ON THESE CUTS ON
OUR PROGRESS AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON THAT II. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE SOME OF
THAT DATA TO SHARE SO WE CAN SEE
NOT JUST THE NUMBERS, BUT WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THESE NUMBERS MEAN
SO BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE TO MAKE
SOME CUTS HERE. WE WANNA KNOW
THAT WE'RE MAKING THEM IN A WAY
THAT IS DOING THE MOST THAT WE
CAN TO CONTINUE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY. I AM SORRY TO TAKE SO
MUCH TIME, BUT I'M I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THE DECISIONS
THAT WE'RE BEING HAVING TO MAKE
AND THE DATA THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE THEM. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ANSWER MATT SCHULER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. UM YOU KNOW, AS OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM FINANCE, YOU
KNOW, UH, REPRESENTED SOME OF
THOSE NUMBERS ARE HARD TO TEASE
OUT WITH RESPECT TO THE NUMBER
OF UNITS THAT ARE BEING FOREGONE
WITH RESPECT TO THE REDUCTIONS,
BUT WE DO HAVE BEEN PROVIDE
INFORMATION WITH RESPECT TO THE
OUTCOMES OF OUR PROGRAMS. AND UM
, NOW THOSE VARY FROM PROGRAM TO
PROGRAM AS ALSO MENTIONED, BUT
WE CERTAINLY SHARE ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION. I'M GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROGRAM
OVERVIEW THAT PROVIDED BUT I'LL
LET MY COLLEAGUE UM UH, FROM THE
DEPARTMENT SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO HOW WE ACTUALLY ASSESS
THAT EFFICACY WITHIN OUR FUNDING
PROGRAMS. HØI GOOD MORNING,
JENNIFER SEEGER AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE DIVISION OF
STATE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AT
THE DEPARTMENT. AND SO TO MY
COLLEAGUE'S POINT. YES WE DID,
UM, CREATE A PROGRAM SUMMARY,
WHICH DETAILS PROGRAM BY PROGRAM
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN OUR PROGRAMS IN
TERMS OF THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED
THROUGH THE FUNDING STREAMS THAT
WE'VE ALLOCATED TO DATE NOW,
WHILE WE DON'T HAVE AN ACTUAL
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THESE WHAT
THESE CUTS MAY CAUSE OF
REDUCTION OF UNITS. WE CAN LOOK
TO SEE WHAT WE'VE ALREADY FUNDED
AND WHAT THE RESULTS ARE OF THAT
. SO UM, I THINK THROUGH THE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY, WE HOPE
TO KIND OF GO THROUGH THOSE
DOCUMENTS. AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THAT, I
THINK WE CAN ANSWER THOSE AS
WELL. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
AND ALSO ANY PROJECTIONS BECAUSE
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW, BY WHAT
IMPACT THESE DOLLARS HAVE
ALREADY CREATED. YOU CAN PROJECT
WHAT WILL BE MISSING. SHOULD WE
CUT THESE PROGRAMS? I THINK THAT
IS CRITICAL INFORMATION, UM,
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL NEED
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BEEN HERE
BEFORE. HOMELESSNESS WAS NOT THE
CRISIS BACK WHEN WE WERE HAVING
MAJOR CUTS. THIS IS A NEW DAY
AND A NEW TIME AND WE NEED A NEW
CRITERIA TO UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
DEEPEST IMPACTS ARE, AND I'M
REALLY DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION TO
HELP US MAKE THESE KINDS OF
DECISIONS. YEAH, I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT IT'S HARD TO TAKE A
DOLLAR AMOUNT AND SAY THAT WILL
RESULT IN A SPECIFIC NUMBER OF
UNITS REDUCED RIGHT BECAUSE OF
THAT CUT BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLICATED FUNDING STACK THAT
OCCURS IN ORDER TO MOVE PROJECTS
FORWARD RIGHT? THEY THEY RECEIVE
MULTIPLE FUNDING SOURCES. SO IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A CUT TO THE M
HÌ P PROGRAM, IT'S HARD TO, UM
MAKE A PROJECTION IN TERMS OF
JUST CUTS TO MH P WILL WILL
RESULT IN A REDUCTION OF THIS
MANY UNITS WHEN THERE'S SO MANY
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THAT ALSO
COME INTO PLAY RIGHT, SO IT'S
NOT A KIND OF A ONE FOR ONE
TYPE. I WILL SAY THIS WHEN WE
HAD THE SURPLUS, THE PROJECTIONS
WERE SHOWING THAT THESE PROGRAMS
WERE WORKING AND NEEDED MORE
FUNDING. SO WHEN WE ARE NOW ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF SHOWING WHEN
THESE CUTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
IMPACT, WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO
BOTH. IF WE CAN JUSTIFY IT TO
GET THE MONEY WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO JUSTIFY THE CUTS TO SAVE THE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK THE MOST.
THAT'S THE POINT I'M MAKING AND
I KNOW THAT THAT IS A COMMON
PRACTICE. UM SO I'M SURE WE HAVE
TO DEVELOP A COMMON PRACTICE IN
THIS HARD TIME, PARTICULARLY
AROUND THIS ISSUE. WE CAN'T DO
IT FOR EVERY ISSUE, BUT I THINK
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS, AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO PULL A BILLION DOLLARS OR
MORE OUT OF THAT PROCESS. WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE REAL DATA
, SO I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
TO HELP US GET AS CLOSE AS WE
CAN TO UNDERSTANDING THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NULAND. THANK YOU. JUST, UH UM
BRIEFLY. WE THE ENTIRE STATE IS
IN THIS UNHAPPY BOAT TOGETHER,
NOT JUST STATE GOVERNMENT, BUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
ENTITIES. AND UH, AS I SAID,
BEFORE, WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO
END UP WITH A BUDGET IN JUNE.
THAT'S GOING TO IRRITATE
EVERYBODY. UM AND THERE'S NÓ
DOUBT GOING TO BE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF CUTS IN THIS AREA.
THE ONE QUALIFICATION THAT I
WOULD THROW OUT IS, TO THE
EXTENT THAT ENTITIES OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BASED UPON A
COMMITMENT HAVE ALREADY SPENT
MONEY BUT HAVE NOT BEEN
REIMBURSED. WE OUGHT TO AVOID
THAT, UM, THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT DIFFICULT TO, UH, TO DEFINE
BECAUSE I'M SURE THAT THERE ARE
SOME WHO WILL SAY I HAVE A
CONTRACT. I CAN'T GET OUT OF
WHEN MAYBE THEY CAN GET OUT OF
IT, SO THERE'S PROBABLY GOING TO
CAUSE A LITTLE BIT OF CONFLICT
ON THAT, BUT AS A AS A GENERAL
RULE, I THINK IT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE TO NOT FUND COMMITMENTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY SPENT LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT HAVE ALREADY SPENT
MONEY BASED UPON THE PRESUMPTION
OF THE OF THE FUNDING. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
MAJORITY OF IT, CERTAINLY, BUT I
DO THINK THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
POINT. I DO APPRECIATE THAT. AND
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS INPUT, I THINK,
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
CIRCUMSTANTIALLY BECAUSE OF THE
EXHAUSTION OF BOND. FUNDING. AND
THE CONSTRAINT SCENARIO. NÓ
MATTER HOW WE DO THIS, WE ARE
LOOKING AT A SUBSTANTIAL
SLOWDOWN OR REDUCTION IN
OPPORTUNITY COSTS, FRANKLY IN
PRODUCTION. AND UH, I'LL BEG TO
DIFFER DUE RESPECT. AS I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THE
DEPARTMENTS DO, BUT, UH I'VE
WORKED AT EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT, LOCAL REGIONAL STATE
AND I'VE DONE POLICY WORK IN THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. WHAT'S ALWAYS
SORT OF INTERESTING IS HOW
DIFFERENT LEVELS HANDLE THEIR
APPROACH TO CONSTRAINT SCENARIOS
. WHAT'S INTERESTING HERE AND TO
THE CENTER SMALL AT CUEVAS POINT
IS WHEN WE LOOK AT SURPLUS WE
FIND IT A LITTLE EASIER TO LOOK
AT HOW FUNDING AVAILABILITY
FINANCING IS COMPOSED WHAT THAT
TRANSLATES TO PROGRAMMATICALLY
INTO CAPACITY. WE HAVE NÓ
PROBLEM DOING THAT. I WOULD BEG
TO DIFFER THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO MAKE ESTIMATES. WELL
INFORMED ESTIMATES ABOUT
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACT. OF THE
REDUCTION OF ELEMENTS OF A
FUNDING STREAM. WE CAN DO THAT.
WE'RE JUST NOT DOING THAT.
THAT'S A FANCY WAY OF SAYING I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE BEING AS
UM PERFORMANCE BASED OR
STRATEGIC AS WE COULD BE, AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT CONSTRAINED
SCENARIO TO THE SENATOR'S POINT.
IT IS NOT JUST A SPREADSHEET.
WHERE WE LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
ONLY AND HOW WE GET THE NUMBERS
DOWN TO WHERE WE NEED TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS,
CONSTITUTIONALLY AND ON AND ON.
BUT THAT IT SHOULD BE MORE
PROGRAM DRIVEN AND THERE SHOULD
BE DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT AND
INTERNAL PROCESS THAT
PRIORITIZES BASED UPON IMPACTS
AND EFFICACY AND CIRCUMSTANCES.
RIGHT AND RANKING THAT AND THEN
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WAYS TO CLOSE
THE GAP BASED UPON THAT
FRAMEWORK, NOT JUST THE TOTALS.
UM THERE BECAUSE THE TOTALS ARE
IRRELEVANT. EXCEPT FOR THEIR
ATTACHED TO PROGRAM. AND THEY
HAVE IMPACTS ON PEOPLE'S LIVES,
AND I THINK THAT'S THE POINT AND
I THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD ONE,
AND IT NEEDS TO BE A CLEARLY
ARTICULATED HERE. IT MIGHT BE
FOR SOME A DIFFERENT WAY OF
LOOKING AT THIS. IT MAY NOT BE
THE WAY WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IT IN
SACRAMENTO. SORRY, BUT THAT
ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH. BOTTOM LINE.
SO TO THAT, I'LL JUST SAY, ARE
THERE OTHER EXISTING
DEPARTMENTAL FUNDS? THAT WERE
MORE DEEPLY EXAMINED THAT COULD
BE UTILIZED IN TERMS OF BEING
HELD OR THAT ARE, UH,
UNAPPROPRIATED THAT COULD
ACHIEVE SAVINGS HERE. AND WHAT
ARE THEY? AND IF NOT, WHY NOT?
MHM. MR CHAIR MEMBERS MAULER
AGAIN FOR THE DEPARTMENT. UM IN
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION, AND
THEN ALSO SENATORS, SENATOR NILO
S¼ OBSERVATION WITH RESPECT TO,
UH, FUNDING THAT IS CURRENTLY
OUT FOR CONSIDERATION. WE'VE
PAUSED PROACTIVELY ANY OF OUR
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
THAT MAY INCLUDE A GENERAL FUND
COMPONENT. SO THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM OVER THE VIEW THAT
I REFERENCED THIS OVERVIEW THAT
WE PROVIDED TO STAFF IS AN
ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF HOW MUCH
GENERAL FUND AVAILABILITY WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THE
DEPARTMENT. AND WHILE THE
REDUCTIONS ARE UNFORTUNATE, UM
TO OUR COLLEAGUE'S POINT OF THE
APPROACH, WE TOOK CONSIDERATION
NOT TO IMPACT THOSE PAST AWARDS
OR ANY NOVAS THAT WERE OPEN AT
THE END OF 2023 RIGHT AT THE
RELEASE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SO THOSE REDUCTIONS THAT
WERE PROPOSED IN JANUARY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW
WOULDN'T IMPACT ANY NOVAS THAT
WERE ACTIVE OR WOULD HAVE ANY
AWARDS THAT WOULD BE ANNOUNCED
IMMINENTLY, SUCH AS OUR
MULTIFAMILY SUPERNOVA? UH WHICH
FUNDS FOUR DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
SO THERE'S VERY LITTLE GENERAL
FUND OUTSIDE OF THE DATA THAT
WE'VE ALREADY PROVIDED TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT IS NOT ALREADY
AWARDED AND ANY REDUCTIONS TO
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ACTIVE WOULD REALLY
REQUIRE PULLING BACK. AWARDS AND
WE FEEL THAT THAT WOULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION. SO UM,
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE ARE
CURRENTLY AND AGAIN. WE CAN TALK
THROUGH SOME OF THE INFORMATION
THAT'S YOU KNOW, BUT THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TO STAFF IN TERMS
OF THOSE AMOUNTS OF GENERAL FUND
THAT ARE REMAINING AND NOT
CURRENTLY OUT FOR CONSIDERATION.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
THINK YOU CAN HEAR IT. YOU KNOW,
FROM MEMBERS THAT PERHAPS GOING
FORWARD, IT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THAT WE HAVE A MORE DETAILED AND
A MORE CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THAT INTERNAL METHODOLOGY
AND ANALYSIS LOOK LIKE AND WHY.
UH, BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'RE LEFT
TO ASK AND TEASE IT OUT, WHICH I
GET IS PART OF THE PROCESS. BUT
TO ME, IT SEEMS THAT SHOULD BE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. IT SHOULD BE
FUNDAMENTAL TO EXPLAIN HOW WE
ARRIVE THERE NOT JUST NOT JUST
HOW WE GET THE NUMBERS DOWN, BUT
HOW WE ARRIVED AT THAT
PRIORITIZATION. I THINK THAT'S
THE POINT. SENATOR NEON. THANK
YOU. JUST ONE MORE COMMENT THAT
I THINK IS IMPORTANT,
PARTICULARLY IN THE CONTEXT OF
ASSESSING WHAT RESULTS. THE
CUTS. MAY END UP, UH, IMPOSING
AND PERHAPS LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN DO MORE WITH LESS. PERHAPS
PARTICULARLY IN A TIME OF CRISIS
. PERHAPS WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT,
UH REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED BY THIS
BODY AT THE STATE LEVEL AS WELL
AS OTHER GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT AND MORE
EXPENSIVE. BUILD HOUSING. UM,
LOCAL FEES. UH DELAYS IN
BUREAUCRATIC APPROVAL PROCESSES.
UM MY DAY. ADD SEQUEL LAWSUITS
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. AND OTHER
THINGS THAT ADD TO THE COST OF
HOUSING BY VIRTUE OF STATE OR
OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS. WE REALLY HAVE NOT
DONE THAT. AND MAYBE WITH
LIMITED FUNDING. AND THEREFORE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE CLOSER TO THE
RESULTS WITH INCREASED FUNDING.
ACHIEVE THAT, WITH REDUCED
FUNDING BY REDUCING COSTS BY
REDUCING BURDENS. THAT MIGHT BE
A WAY FOR YOU TO LOOK AT AND
BRING REC RECOMMENDATIONS AS
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SMALL AND I
WANT TO JUST ECHO THE CHAIRS,
STATEMENTS ABOUT THE IMPACT. I
UNDERSTAND. YOU PROVIDED THIS TO
STAFF. WHAT WHAT I'M SAYING, UM
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR FOR ME.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH. WE NEED AN
IMPACT ASSESSMENT OF THESE VERY
LARGE CUTS IN THESE AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN LAID OUT BEFORE US. UM
HOWEVER, YOU PROJECTED THE
AMOUNTS FOR INVESTMENT. WE NEED
A PROJECTION OF WHAT THE CUTS
WILL CREATE IN TERMS OF IMPACT
TO THOSE PROGRAMS AND TO, UM YOU
KNOW, THE LAST STATEMENT MADE WE
DIDN'T JUST GET HERE YESTERDAY.
UM WE ARE TRYING TO BUILD BACK A
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS
STATE THAT DATES BACK TO THE
EIGHTIES. UM AND SEVENTIES AND,
UM IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN DO OVERNIGHT, BUT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE A PRIORITY
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION. UH AND
OUR GOAL IS TO GET OUR PEOPLE
HOUSED AND OFF THE STREET AND,
UM THIS IS NOT THE TIME AS WE
HAVE INFLATION AS WE SEE
UNCERTAINTY AT OUR AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. THIS IS NOT THE
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO PULL THE
RUG FROM UNDERNEATH THIS THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR THAT WE
ARE INVOLVED IN TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. UM, BUT ALSO, UM,
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA IS A IS A
PLACE WHERE WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
OWN. UM SO II. I WANT TO JUST
REINFORCE THE NEED FOR US TO
HAVE MORE DATA TO BE ABLE TO SEE
THOSE IMPACTS AND TO SEE IT
BEFORE THIS COMES BEFORE US
AGAIN. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE THAT, UH,
OVERARCHING PRESENTATION.
APPRECIATE THE LAOS INPUT
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSES FOR
SORT OF SETTING THE FOUR CORNERS
HERE AND THE ENGAGEMENT BY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMITTEE WITH
THAT WE'LL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE, WHICH IS REDUCTIONS TO THE
REGIONAL EARLY ACTION PLANNING
GRANTS REAP 2.0.
LITTLE BIT OF MUSICAL CHAIRS,
RIGHT? ALL RIGHT, WITH ISSUE
FIVE. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
FOR THE RECORD. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. HØI I'M MEGAN KIRKY.
UM OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
HOUSING POLICY DEVELOPMENT AT
HC. WHERE THE REAP 2.0 PROGRAM
IS SITUATED. AND AGAIN, MATT
SCHULER, ADMIN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT, AND WE WOULD
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO START THE
CONVERSATION ON THE PLEASE
PROCEED. YES BLAIR HUXMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UM, SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
$300 MILLION GENERAL FUND
REVERSION FOR THE REGIONAL EARLY
ACTION PLANNING GRANTS PROGRAM.
UM OR 2.02 0.0 PROVIDES FUNDING
TO ADVANCE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ADOPTED REGIONAL PLANS BY
FUNDING, PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES THAT
ACCELERATE AND FILL HOUSING. THE
2021 BUDGET INCLUDED 600,000,001
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
REGIONAL EARLY ACTION PLANNING
2.0 PROGRAM. AND WITH THE
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU,
APPROXIMATELY THREE 100 MILLION
GENERAL FUND OR ABOUT 50%
REMAINS FOR THIS PROGRAM. OF THE
L Ó HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT? THANK YOU, MR CHAIR
JENNY BELLO WITH THE ANALYSTS
OFFICE. WE WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ONES WHERE
WE HAVE, ALTHOUGH THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS SOMEWHAT
LOW AT THIS POINT, AS YOUR
AGENDA POINTS OUT, WE HAVE HEARD
FROM STAKEHOLDERS THAT ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES ON THE GROUND MAY
BE MORE AND THAT MORE
REIMBURSEMENTS WILL BE COMING IN
. SO I THINK THAT'S AN AREA FOR
THE SUBCOMITTEE TO EXPLORE
TODAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AS I INDICATED EARLIER. WE
WILL INVITE COMMENT. UH AS TO
EACH ISSUE SPECIFIC BEFORE WE
TAKE UP SORT OF A DIALOGUE, BUT
TO THAT END BECAUSE ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS OF DISCUSSING THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE IS FRANKLY,
SOME OF THE PLANNING OR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT, YOU KNOW, PROGRAM
PROGRESS THAT MAY WELL BE
INTERRUPTED OR FRUSTRATED IN
WAYS THAT ARE NOT PERHAPS
PRAGMATIC OR APPROPRIATE. UH AND
THAT INVOLVES A LOT OF REGIONAL
PLANNING ENTITIES. I'M IN A
FIRST IN THIS VEIN INVITE BILL
HIGGINS, THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COGS. UH, MR TURIN IS WELCOME.
THANK YOU. I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING A SORT OF A
MULTIORGAN ORGANIZATIONAL, BROAD
TOPICALLY APPROPRIATE. AREA SO
FIVE MINUTES OR SO BE SUFFICED
AND AGAIN, PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD AND WELCOME
VERY MUCH. BILL HIGGINS I'M, THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS, AND WE
REPRESENT ALL 18 METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
GETTING THE $510 MILLION POT.
UH, WE ALSO REPRESENT 30. OTHER
REGIONAL ENTITIES THAT WILL BE
SUB ALLOCATED SOME OF THESE
FUNDS AS WELL AS PARTICIPATING
IN THE TWO COMPETITIVE FUNDING
POTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN RE AND
I WANNA ADDRESS TWO THINGS AND I
HOPEFULLY I WON'T TAKE ALL MY
FIVE MINUTES. UM AND I WANNA
ADDRESS FIRST THIS IDEA THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE NOT ALLOCATED
AND I JUST WANNA EXPLAIN THE
PROCESS THAT THIS FUND HAS. THIS
IS A NEW FUND. FOR US. IT'S IN
THE STATE, AND IT'S A IT'S JUST
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. SO WHEN
THIS WAS PASSED AND REALIZED
WE'RE 30 MONTHS INTO THIS
PROGRAM. AND WHEN IT WAS PAST,
THE FIRST THING OUR MEMBERS HAD
TO DO WAS ENGAGE IN PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. TO GET FEEDBACK ON
WHAT WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE FOR
THE PROGRAM. AND THEN WE HAD TO
DEVELOP A BUDGET. TO EXPLAIN
WHAT WE WERE GOING TO DO WITH
THE FUNDS THAT WE PRESENTED TO
HÌ èC Dð AND HÌ èC Dð BECAUSE
ALSO HAD TO SHARE AND GET
FEEDBACK WITH Ó PR AND A RB.
AND THEY GAVE US COMMENTS BACK
WHEN WE AGREED ON A BUDGET WE
HAD TO ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
WITH HÌ èC Dð. AND THEN WE
AWARDED THE FUNDS IN WHICH WE
HAD TO ENGAGE IN A GRANT
AGREEMENT WITH THE SUB AWARDEE.
THEY HAD TO ACTUALLY START THEIR
OWN CONTRACTS TO OBTAIN
CONTRACTORS INCUR EXPENSE.
SUBMIT THAT EXPENSE TO US. AND
THEN WE HAVE TO SUBMIT IT TO HÌ
èC Dð. THAT'S AN UNUSUAL
PROCESS, AND IT SUGGESTS WHY
THERE MIGHT BE MORE OF A BALANCE
ON HÌ CDS. BOOKS DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S 30 MONTHS OF
WORK DONE ON THIS. SO WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN? WELL, IN THE MOST
EXTREME EXAMPLE THERE'S A
PROJECT. I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN TULARE
COUNTY. THREE PROJECTS FOR ALL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ONE OF THEM
IS A HOMELESS SHELTER, ALL
LOCATED CLOSE TO TRANSIT CENTERS
AND SOME OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE. ARE THESE THE ALL THESE
PROJECTS HAVE ELECTRIC CAR
SHARE. UM THAT IS DESIGNED TO
WORK WITH THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY HAVE PRE NEGOTIATED, UH,
AFTER CARE WITH THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THEY'RE LOCATED ON A
PLANNED CROSS COUNTY RAIL LINE
THAT WOULD EVENTUALLY BISECT
HIGH SPEED RAIL. AND THESE TWO
OF THE PROJECTS ARE DONE.
STARTING AN OCCUPANCY AND THE
DEVELOPER STILL CARRYING COSTS
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET THE
REIMBURSEMENT ON THAT PROJECT.
SO TO SAY THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
SITTING IN THE STATE WHEN THEY
AND NOT ALLOCATED, I THINK IS
THE PROCESS HAS BEEN THAT NOW
THERE'S ALSO BEEN DELAYS IN THIS
AND MY FRIENDS AT HÌ èC Dð ARE
PARTNERS. WE FACILITATE A
MEETING WITH OUR PROJECT
DIRECTORS AND HÌ èC Dð MONTHLY
AND HÌ èC Dð HAS BEEN A LITTLE
BIT SLOW AT TIMES AND APPROVING
EVEN THE BUDGETS BECAUSE THEY'RE
OVERWORKED. THEY'RE DOING
HOUSING ELEMENTS, BUT TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE MTC SUBMITTED
THEIR BUDGET AND IT TOOK 11
MONTHS TO GET IT APPROVED. SO IF
YOU LOOK AT M Tð èC S¼
ALLOCATIONS RIGHT NOW THEY LOOK
LIKE THEY'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING.
BUT THEY COULDN'T DO ANYTHING.
WORK HAS BEEN DONE ON THIS MONEY
, SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO. I JUST KINDA WANNA THIS.
THIS FUNDING IS UNIQUE. IT'S NEW
BECAUSE IT SITS AT THE NEXUS OF
TWO IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA GOALS,
CLIMATE AND HOUSING. AND I WANT
TO INTRODUCE THE IDEA THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL SO WHAT IT
REAPS. THAT'S MY HASHTAG. UM BUT
OUR MEMBERS ARE THE ENTITIES
THAT DISTRIBUTE THE ARENA. WE'RE
ALSO THE ONES THAT DEVELOP THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
. AND WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THESE
PROJECTS, WHETHER IT'S THE GREEN
MEANS GO PROGRAM AND SAY COG
THAT'S DOING EARLY FIRST TIME
INVESTMENT. I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY MOANING MORE
ABOUT THAT THE SEWER PIPES IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NEEDED
TO BUILD THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
CLOG REGION. FOR IT'S THE HIT
GRANT THAT SAND GOT IN SAN LUCID
THAT'S ALLOWING RENT TO OWN
PROGRAMS, OR THERE'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TRUSTS ACROSS THE SAG
REGION. THE VENTURA COUNTY UM,
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IS
FUNDING $5 MILLION TO A PROGRAM.
THAT LOOKS WHEN THEY LEVERAGE IT
WITH ALL THE OTHER FUNDS THAT
THEY'LL GET IS ESTIMATING 650
UNITS PRODUCED AND THIS IS THE
TYPE OF ANALYSIS THAT HASN'T
BEEN. I CAN GO ON AND ON ABOUT
THESE PROJECTS BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF THEM, BUT I THINK WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU IS TAKE A
HARDER LOOK. WHEN WE'RE
ALLOCATING THESE FUNDS. I
APPRECIATE THE L. I Ó S¼ REPORT
THAT IS IDENTIFIED A LOT MORE
POTENTIAL FUNDS. I THINK YOU
HAVE TO LOOK HARD AT WHAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN OBLIGATED AND NOT
JUST HANDED OUT. BUT WHAT WORK
HAS BEEN DONE. AND THEN THE
SECOND ELEMENT IS HOW MANY
CRITICAL CALIFORNIA GOALS IS
THIS FUND SEEKING TO ACHIEVE AND
HERE IT'S NOT JUST HOUSING. IT'S
ALSO CLIMATE AND IT'S HOW WE
GROW. SO CALIFORNIA WILL SOW
WHAT IT REAPS. CAME WITH THE A
GAME AND VERY WELL SAID I LIKE
IT. I APPRECIATE THAT, SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME, AND BUT
ALL RIGHT, I'LL INVITE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT SPECIFICALLY
WITH RESPECT TO ISSUE FIVE AND
REAP 2.0. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD.
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TIME TO ABOUT
ONE MINUTE. THANK YOU. WELCOME
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS, AND TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO URGE
YOU TO PROTECT THE RE TWO POINT
Ó PROGRAM. UM AS UM BILL
HIGGINS MENTIONED WHEN WE ECHO
HIS EVERYTHING HE JUST SAID HIS
HASHTAG. THIS. PROGRAM IS ABOUT
VERY REAL PROJECTS TO SENATOR
SMALL CUEVAS IS LIKE QUESTIONING
. WE HAVE THE DATA TO TELL YOU,
SENATOR NILO CUEVAS, SMALL
CUEVAS. WHAT EXACTLY IS AT RISK
AT STAKE FROM THIS PROGRAM? SURE
THEY'D BE CUT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT TO EACH OF YOU. SO
WE, WE THANK YOU FOR TAKING A
DEEPER LOOK AT THIS PROGRAM. WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND SOLUTIONS
FOR THIS YEAR AND MANY YEARS TO
COME. UH, FOR THE WEEK TWO.
PROGRAM. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE WITH
POLITICO GROUP ON BEHALF OF A
COUPLE OF CLIENTS THIS AFTERNOON
, THE FIRST BEING THE COACHELLA
VALLEY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS, UH, WOULD JUST
SUGGEST TO YOU THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO SEE VERY SIMILAR
IMPACTS AS THOSE THAT MR HIGGINS
DESCRIBED. UH, TWO OF THEIR
PROJECTS ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT CLOSE TO 6200 INFILL
HOUSING UNITS IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY, AND THERE'S ALSO
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS RELATED TO ADDITIONAL
CONNECTIONS FOR èC VÆ LINK AND
A MULTIMODAL TRANSIT SUPPORTIVE
RAIL STATION. SO LOTS OF GOOD
WORK GOING ON IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT. UM, ADDITIONALLY, I
REPRESENT THE TULARE COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENT, SO I
JUST WANT TO ADD ON, UH, TO
WHAT? UH, BILL SHARED ABOUT
THEIR PROJECTS. THEY HAVE A
REALLY UNIQUE, FANTASTIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES, BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN AN
AREA THAT DESPERATELY NEEDS IT
AND THEY ARE READY TO GIVE UP AT
THIS POINT, I THINK, BECAUSE THE
PROCESS HAS BEEN SO FRUSTRATING.
JUST WANT TO REALLY EMPHASIZE
HIS TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF Tð
èC A AS WELL, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JULIE SNYDER AGAIN REPRESENTING
MØT èC, A BAG IN THE BAY AREA
HOUSING FINANCE AUTHORITY, OUR
STATE MANDATED SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY WILL REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY 19%
AND SUPPORT 400,000 NEW,
AFFORDABLE HOMES IF WE CAN FULLY
IMPLEMENT IT PROVIDES THE ONLY
FLEXIBLE STATE FUNDING. THIS
VISION TO REALITY. AFTER TWO
YEARS OF BACK AND FORTH WITH
THIS VERY OVERWORKED STATE STAFF
AS MR HIGGINS MENTIONED, UH, WE
DID RECENTLY GET OUR PLAN
APPROVED. TWO THIRDS OF THAT
GRANT IS DEDICATED TO DIRECT
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND TO
PROVIDING AWARD WINNING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO OUR
LOCALITIES TO HELP THEM MEET
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT GOALS.
THIS INCLUDES A PILOT PROGRAM TO
MODEL NEW APPROACHES TO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON LARGE
CAPACITY SITES LIKE AGING MOLES
PARKING LOT. YOU KNOW THOSE
SITES THAT WE ALL WANNA SEE
REDEVELOPED IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
UM AND IT'S DESIGNED TO
ACCELERATE THE USE OF LAND, IN
PARTICULAR IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS
AND REALLY CREATE SOME SHOWCASE
PRECEDENT SETTING PROJECTS. UM
OUR SECOND HOUSING PROGRAM IS
GONNA PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN DISADVANTAGED
DISINVESTED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE NÓ FUNDING FOR THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY. UM THE PRODUCTION
PROGRAMS WILL BUILD AND PRESERVE
UP TO 1600 APARTMENTS AND OVER
THE LONG TERM DEED RESTRICTIONS
WILL HOUSE AN ESTIMATED 14,000
HOUSEHOLDS. SO YOU WANNA TALK
ABOUT IMPACT? THERE'S SOME
IMPACT FOR YOU, UM THE REMAINDER
OF OUR GRANT IS FOCUSED ON
WRITER IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
TRANSIT SYSTEM, TRYING TO MAKE
OUR BOTH OUR FAIR CO ORDINATION
AND OUR MAPPING MORE ALIGNED
ACROSS THE BAY AREA SO THAT AS A
WRITER WE WOULD REDUCE BOTH COST
AND THE CHALLENGES OF NAVIGATING
FROM BUS TO FERRY, UH TO RAIL.
SO LAST THING I WANNA SAY IS
THAT ALTHOUGH WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON GETTING THE FINAL
PLAN APPROVED, WE HAVE ACTUALLY
SIGNED CONTRACTS TO START SOME
OF THIS WORK. WE ISSUED NÓ FUZZ.
WE'VE HIRED STAFF, SO A 50% CUT
AT THIS POINT WOULD REALLY BE
UNPRECEDENTED. GIVEN WHERE WE
ARE IN IMPLEMENTATION, SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO
CHECK THE AUDIO THAT THERE IS IT
JUST TOO CLOSE TO THE MIC. ALL
RIGHT. JUST THE MIC IS SENSITIVE
. SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE NOT AT
ALL, HEY, WE ARE I DO IT ALL THE
TIME. AND WE WANNA BE HEARD. SO
IT JUST DEPENDS. SO I HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN. PLEASE PROCEED.
WELCOME. AND, UH, MEMBERS, JAMES
CORLESS, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SACRAMENTO AREA, COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS, OR SE HOG IN THE
SIX COUNTY, GREATER SACRAMENTO
REGION. UH I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS EARLIER. THESE FUNDS
ARE RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT IN
OUR REGION ABOUT 34 MILLION.
THEY ARE CRITICAL TO MEETING THE
STATES, THE STATES CLIMATE AND
HOUSING GOALS. WE HAVE AWARDED
THESE FUNDS. THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO SHOW UP AS REIMBURSEMENTS YET
JUST LIKE MR HIGGINS HAD SAID.
SO YOU WON'T SEE THAT YET, BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN AWARDED
COMPETITIVELY TO JURISDICTION.
WE HAVE 26 GRANTS OUT THERE TO
DO WATER, SEWER AND UTILITY
UPGRADES ALL ACROSS OUR REGION
THAT WILL UNLOCK 8000 UNITS OF
HOUSING. OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE BIDS. THEY ARE NOT GONNA
MOVE ON THOSE BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH THE WITH THESE FUNDS. SO
THEY ARE WAITING FOR THE OUTCOME
OF THE STATE BUDGET AND THESE
REFUNDS A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE TO MEET
THE STATE'S CLIMATE, HOUSING AND
REALLY GOOD JOBS DOING
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR OUR REGION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS CAN SWALLOW
HERNANDEZ FROM THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO, UM, FOLLOWING UP ON
JAMES'S COMMENTS. WE ARE ONE OF
THE SAY COG CITIES AND JUST
WANTED TO GIVE YOU A LOCAL
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THESE
PROJECTS. HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE,
UM WE HAVE BEEN AWARDED THREE
$0.9 MILLION TO, UH, MAKE SEWER
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE DEL DEL PASO
BOULEVARD AREA. IT'S ONE OF OUR
INFILL AREAS WHERE AN OLD CITY
WE'VE GOT AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WAS NEVER INTENDED TO
SUPPORT THE NUMBER OF RESIDENTS
THAT WE HAVE NOW, MUCH LESS THE
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS THAT HOPE TO
HAVE, UM, ONE OF THE KEY
PROJECTS IN THERE IS THE BRIDGE
HOUSING PROJECT. THIS IS
ACTUALLY A STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTY. UM THAT IS MEANING THE
GOVERNOR'S GOALS OF TURNING THAT
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ALL OF
THE PROJECTS IN THE AREA WILL
CREATE ABOUT 800 OR I'M SORRY.
600 UNITS OF HOUSING, UH, MUCH
OF WHICH WILL BE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BECAUSE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SO OLD. WE
HAVE HAD A LOT OF VACANT
PROPERTIES THAT DEVELOPERS JUST
AREN'T ABLE TO DEVELOP. IF THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO MAKE ALL OF THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS, SO THIS SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY WILL SEE A BOON
IN HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. ALL UP
AND DOWN THE SCALE. THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. UH, THANK YOU FOR
HEARING ME OUT. UH, MY NAME IS
ROBERT PHIPPS, INTERIM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH FRESNO COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS, ECHOING EARLIER
COMMENTS IN OUR REGION. THE CUT
OFF FOR OUR UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AFFECTS OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED CITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CITY OF SAN
JOAQUIN WILL LOSE A TRAIL'S
CONNECTION. UH UH. PROJECT. UH,
THAT IS ONLY A MILLION.
UNFORTUNATELY UH, THAT IS THE
HARD MATH OF IT THAT, UH,
CONNECTS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS UNDER HOUSING
AUTHORITY. UH, PROGRAM THAT
MULTIFAMILY DEVELOPMENTS. UH,
THAT WAS AWARDED, UH, WITH HÌ
èC Dð, UH, SITTING ON OUR
SUBCOMITTEE AWARDING THAT, UH
UH, PROJECT ALONG WITH A COUPLE
OF OTHERS, UH, ONE OF WHICH IS
ALSO BEING CUT OUR FUNDING
PRIMARILY GOING INTO
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO SUPPORT INFILL DEVELOPMENT
AND SO BUT NECESSARY. INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT SETS THE STAGE FOR
YOU KNOW THESE DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR GROWING, UH, LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS LE WITH POLITICO GROUP
HERE ON BEHALF OF A COUPLE
CLIENTS. FIRST THE MERCED COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS HAS A
$3.9 MILLION AWARD FROM THE RE
PROGRAM. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT FUNDING ABOUT 2.7 MILLION
IS GOING TO SUPPORT A CAPITAL
PROJECT, AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT IN DOWNTOWN MERCED. IT'S
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S CLOSE TO EXISTING AMTRAK
AND BUS SERVICE, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, CLOSE TO THE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
STATION IN THAT JURISDICTION THE
REMAINDER OF THEIR FUNDING. HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED FOR REZONING FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE HOUSING ELEMENT
. THE RENA ALLOCATIONS MADE BY
THE ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
TO THEIR SMALL CITIES, AND PAY
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW,
AND ALL OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO PLAN FOR THAT
FUTURE GROWTH IN CLIMATE
FRIENDLY AREAS THAT SUPPORT M
èC A'S SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGY AND ACHIEVE THOSE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS, AND THEN FINALLY FOR
THE SONOMA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY, REGIONAL CLIMATE
PROTECTION AUTHORITY JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY A BAG AND FOR BOTH
CLIENTS URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
REVERSION OF REFUNDING. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LAUREN DE VALENCIA, REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION. OUR MEMBERS ARE THE
FOLKS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHO ARE
IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THE LAWS
THAT HAVE PASSED YEAR OVER YEAR
WORKING VERY HARD TO UPDATE
HOUSING ELEMENTS AND ALL THESE
PROJECTS THAT, UH, MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY ECHOED. UM BUT WHAT
WE ARE HEARING FROM OUR MEMBERS
IS THAT THEY ARE UNDER RESOURCED
, AND THEY ARE VERY MUCH UNDER
CAPACITY FOR WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO TO GET THIS WORK DONE. AND SO
THE RE TWO POINT Ó PROGRAM HAS
REALLY BEEN HELPFUL TO BE ABLE
TO DO SOME OF THAT GOOD PLANNING
WORK, AND WE ARE NOW VERY
CONCERNED TO SEE THAT THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY BE CLAWED BACK, AND
WE REALLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO REJECT THIS PROPOSAL AND
CONTINUE TO FUND THAT PLANNING
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO BE
ABLE TO REACH OUR CLIMATE AND
HOUSING GOALS THAT WE ALL SHARE.
THANK YOU. MR CHAIR MEMBERS, AMY
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST SACRAMENTO. WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH, SAY, COG AND THE
GREEN BEAN SCOPE PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR, UM, IN WEST
SACRAMENTO. WE HAVE ALREADY
MATCHED $4 MILLION IN GREEN
BEANS GO FUNDING WITH A MILLION
IN CITY FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT THE
WASHINGTON DISTRICT UNDERGROUND
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INFILL UPGRADE PROJECT. UH AND
SO WE OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
. UH, KIRK BLACKBURN HERE ON
BEHALF OF, UH, SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENT SAND.
SO UH, WHO'S A REGIONAL
COLLABORATOR WITH THE WORKING
SIDE BY SIDE OF THE STATE TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE, HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. SAND. E IS
DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO REAP 2.0. AS
DOING SO WE'RE ONLY EXACERBATES
THE STATE'S CLIMATE AND HOUSING
CRISES. UH, SAN DIE HAS UTILIZED
THESE CRITICAL REFUNDS TO
ADDRESS REGIONAL HOUSING ISSUES
BY LAUNCHING ITS HOUSING
ACCELERATION PROGRAM, OR HAP.
UH, THROUGH THIS PROGRAM SAN HAS
ALREADY AWARDED 12 POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THREE 0.22
0.0 FUNDING FOR 15 PROJECTS TO
IMPLEMENT LOCAL HOUSING ELEMENTS
, ACCELERATE DEVELOPMENT,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HELP THE
REGION REACH ITS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS. UH, THIS
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR, UH,
CRITICAL HOUSING PROJECTS IN
IMPERIAL BEACH AND NATIONAL
CITY. WITH THE PROPOSED CUTS TO
2.0. THESE PROJECTS ARE NOW
PLACED IN SERIOUS JEOPARDY. SO
AS SUCH, SANDY STRONGLY URGES,
THE LEGISLATURE REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUTS AND
PRESERVE EXISTING FUNDING
AMOUNTS FOR 2.0. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS MARISA BROWN.
I'M REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
CITRUS HEIGHTS TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME. I AM HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE WHEN I'M SURE WHEN YOU
THINK OF CITRUS HEIGHTS, I'M
SURE YOU THINK OF SHOPPING AT
SUNRISE MALL, SUNRISE MALL HAS
STOOD AS A LANDMARK AND CITRUS
HEIGHTS FOR A LONG TIME NOW, BUT
IN RECENT YEARS, IT'S LOST ITS
SHINE THE SUNRISE TOMORROW
PACIFIC PLAN, WHICH IS A
RECIPIENT OF GREEN MEANS GO
FUNDING ALLOWS US TO BREATHE NEW
LIFE INTO OUR CITY. IF YOU
HAVEN'T HAD THE CHANCE TO LOOK
AT THE PLAN YOURSELF YET, LET ME
GIVE YOU A GLIMPSE OF WHAT THIS
COULD HOLD FOR OUR RESIDENTS,
BUSINESSES AND OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS PLAN TRANS TRANSFORMS 100
ACRES OF CURRENT RETAIL SPACE
AND PARKING LOT INTO MIXED USE,
TRANSIT ORIENTED VILLAGE WITH
2200 RESIDENTIAL UNITS, 480
HOTEL ROOMS, RETAIL SPACE OFFICE
, SPACE COMMUNITY AND
INSTITUTIONAL USES AND 25 ACRES
OF OPEN AND GREEN SPACE FOR A
CITY THAT'S 14.6 SQUARE MILES
ARE BUILT OUT. 2200 NEW
RESIDENTIAL UNITS WILL MAKE A
HUGE IMPACT FOR ON OUR
AVAILABILITY TO PROVIDE AFFORD.
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOOKING TO LIVE IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS. AND IN THE SACRAMENTO
REGION. USING THESE 100 ACRES
ALLOWS US TO CREATE INFILL
HOUSING IN A MORE ECONOMICAL,
ENVIRONMENTAL AND FISCALLY SOUND
WAY. THE GREEN MEANS GO FUNDING
IS NEEDED TO PLAN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAPACITIES AND
PHASING REQUIRED TO MAKE
REDEVELOPMENT IN IN AND INFILL
HOUSING POSSIBLE FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES LOOKING
TO CALL CITRUS HEIGHTS HOME.
WHILE MANY MALLS IN OUR AREA ARE
BEGINNING TO EXPERIENCE THE SAME
HARDSHIPS AS SUNRISE MALL, THE
SUNRISE TOMORROW SPECIFIC PLAN
LOOKS TO BE AN EXAMPLE FOR OUR
REGION AND FOR OUR STATE ON WHAT
A BRIGHT FUTURE CAN LOOK LIKE.
GREEN MEANS GO FUNDING IS
CRITICAL PART IN MAKING THIS A
REALITY. THE $1 BILLION PRICE
TAG TO BUILD OUT THE SITE TO
COMPLETION REQUIRES $100 100
MILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THIS
GROWTH, IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING, THE PROJECT
IS ANTICIPATED TO RESULT IN $99
BILLION. PLEASE CONCLUDE THANK
YOU. HØI WELCOME. HØI JEANNIE
WARD WALLER, UM, ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORM, WHICH IS BASED IN THE
BAY AREA, HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION GROUP. UM, WE
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSED
CUT TO RE THANK YOU. RIGHT? GET
BACK TO UP ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. SENATOR. DO YOU WANT
TO GO FIRST? NÓ QUESTIONS JUST
THAT POINTS OUT THE DIFFICULTY
HERE. A FEW OF THOSE TESTIFIERS
ARE FROM DIRECTLY FROM MY
DISTRICT. THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COGS.
ILLUSTRATED THE DIFFICULTY IN
IDENTIFYING THE FUNDS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SPENT. OR UH,
IRREVERSIBLY COMMITTED. BUT
BEYOND THAT POINT RELATIVE TO
THE UM THE PRIORITIES OF THE
STATE. AND FUNDING BEYOND THAT
POINT. I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT UH, EVERY DOLLAR THAT IS,
UM NOT EVERY DOLLAR OF CUTS
THAT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THE
EVENTUAL BUDGET. WILL HAVE TO BE
CUT SOMEPLACE ELSE. AND THEN
WILL HAVE TO FIND MORE CUTS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT THERE YET. SO
FURTHER POINTING OUT THE
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT SITUATION
WE'RE FACED WITH. THANK YOU, SIR
. CAN YOU, UH, TO THE TO FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT? HOW DID WE END
UP LANDING ON ROUTE 2.0 AS A
PROGRAM APPROPRIATE FOR CUTTING
UM, AND IF SO, IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE ULTIMATELY TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSAL, HOW WOULD
THIS BE IMPLEMENTED AND WHAT
WOULD BE THE QUALIFYING
THRESHOLDS? PROGRAMMATICALLY
EITHER ARE BOTH. PLEASE ADDRESS
THAT. ANDREW MARCH, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, I'LL. I'LL TAKE IT
THE FIRST PART AND THEN AND
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT. BUT
SPECIFICALLY, I MEAN, AS YOU
KNOW, THE JANUARY BUDGET. IT WAS
ALL OF THE ABOVE APPROACH. I
MEAN, WE WERE YOU KNOW, IN AN
EFFORT TO PRESENT A BALANCED
BUDGET, THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
TO LOOK THROUGH VARIOUS PROGRAMS
THAT RECEIVE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
. OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT ORIGINALLY
THE RE 2.0 PROGRAM HAD $500
MILLION OF FEDERAL FUNDING AND
$100 MILLION OF GENERAL FUND AT
THE URGING OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT
THERE'S DIFFICULTIES COMPLYING
WITH SOME OF THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE FUNDING
THAT FUNDING WAS SWAPPED TO
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY WITH GENERAL
FUND THE FEDERAL FUND WITH
GENERAL FUND, WHICH IS HOW WE
GET TO THE $600 MILLION GENERAL
FUND TOTAL, SO YOU KNOW, DESPITE
THE REDUCTION, THREE 100 MILLION
STILL REMAINS, WHICH IS WHICH IS
A SLY, LARGE INVESTMENT FOR THIS
TYPE OF PROGRAM. UM ALBEIT
UNDERSTANDING THAT, UH, VARIOUS,
UM COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENT ARE IN
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS AND IT MAY
BE DIFFICULT TO PRIORITIZE. UM
HOWEVER, UM, YOU KNOW THIS. THIS
PROPOSAL DOESN'T INCLUDE ANY
PRIORITIZATION, HOWEVER, THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ULTIMATELY
IMPLEMENT WHATEVER IS ADOPTED IN
THE BUDGET. SO IF THE HAS
CERTAIN PRIORITIES OR THOUGHTS
ON HOW TO PRIORITIZE REMAINING
FUNDING. IF THERE IS A
REDUCTION, THE ADMINISTRATION IS
OPEN TO DISCUSSING THAT, AND
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR DEFER
TO MY DEPARTMENT TO CLARIFY
ANYTHING THAT I'VE SAID
APPRECIATE THAT. I THINK I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT IT'S CLEAR
FROM THE TESTIMONY AND A LOT OF
THE FURTHER INPUT THAT BY VIRTUE
OF HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
ADMINISTRATED ADMINISTERED,
THERE'S A DE FACTO ENCUMBRANCES
FOR PORTIONS OF THIS FUNDING
FROM A PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND POINT. SO ON
A LEDGER, WE CAN SAY THOSE ALIGN
WITH MORE BROADLY UNENCUMBERED
FUNDS GENERAL FUND AND ALIGN
WITH, YOU KNOW FUNDS THAT ARE IN
LAYMAN'S TERMS FREE FOR THE
SWEEPING PROGRAMMATICALLY. IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THAT'S THE
CASE. AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE
THAT'S A CONCERN ANYWHERE. I
WOULD DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY HOW MUCH
FUNDING HAS BEEN SPENT. UH, YES.
ABSOLUTELY SO THIS DOES DIFFER
FROM THE OTHER PROGRAMS YOU
HEARD ABOUT TODAY AND THAT LIKE
THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN AWARDED
AND THAT THAT LONG PERIOD YOU
WERE HEARING ABOUT IS BECAUSE
THIS HAS BEEN A PARTNERSHIP. UM
WE'VE WORKED REALLY CLOSELY WITH
EACH OF THE ALLOCATED AGENCIES
ON THOSE PLANS TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT THEY MATCH THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES. AND SO WE'RE I CAN'T
HELP BUT BE A LITTLE PROUD, YOU
KNOW, HEARING OUT LOUD, SOME OF
THE THINGS WE WORKED ON IN THIS
PROGRAM. THAT SAID, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS THAT'S THIS IS THE YEAR
WE'RE IN. UM AND, UM UH, 300
MILLION IS NOT NOTHING AND TO
KEEP GOING WITH THIS PROGRAM. UM
WE HAVE TRIED TO BE VERY
TRANSPARENT WITH OUR AWARDEES.
AS SOON AS WE LEARNED, UM UM OF
THEIR THE PROPOSED REDUCTION,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT, UM, REIMBURSEMENTS AT
THIS TIME TO HELP PEOPLE PLAN
AHEAD AS FAR AS THEY CAN. UM SO
WE, UM WE ARE AWARE, UM YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE REIMBURSEMENTS
COMING IN, UM AND WE'RE AWARE
THAT, UM YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
CONTRACTS IN PLACE. UM,
CONTRACTS DO HAVE, UM, TYPICALLY
HAVE LANGUAGE ABOUT, UM, YOU
KNOW, BUDGET CHANGES IN BUDGET
AND FISCAL ENVIRONMENT. UM AND
ABSOLUTELY, UM YOU KNOW WHEN THE
WHEN THE DUST SETTLES, YOU KNOW,
WE ARE PAUSING REIMBURSEMENTS
BEYOND 25% SO THAT, UM WHEN WE
KNOW WHAT THE FINAL FINAL
DECISIONS ARE HERE, UM WE CAN
HAVE INFORMED CONVERSATIONS WITH
ALL OF OUR AWARDEES ABOUT, UM,
PRIORITIZING AMONG THE REMAINING
THE REMAINING FUNDS AVAILABLE.
UM YOU KNOW, AS AS YOU HAVE
SHARED, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A PLACE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE, UM, TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE SHOULD THEY
SO DESIRE IN THAT SPACE, UM I
THINK YOU ASKED ME ONE MORE
QUESTION. I FORGOT TO ANSWER,
BUT, UM, TO IMPLEMENTATION. AND
THE CRITERIA FOR HOW GIVEN THE
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS AND THE
DIFFERENT STAGES OF DIFFERENT
VARIOUS PRODUCT PROJECTS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY AFFECTED DIRECTLY.
HOW WOULD WE ACHIEVE THAT? SO AT
THE MOMENT, UM, OTHER THAN THE
PROPOSED REDUCTION, THERE'S NÓ
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL ABOUT HOW TO
ACTIVATE THAT WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT EVERY SINGLE UM OR COME
TALK TO US IF THEY ARE, UM IF
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO EXCEED EVEN 25% OF THEIR
AWARDING, UM AND SO WE HAVE
HEARD FROM SOME OF OUR AWARDEES
THERE, BUT, UM, THAT THAT'S SORT
OF THE PATH WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW
IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
WHERE IS EVERYBODY AT? UM SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE AS MUCH TO
DECISION MAKERS AS POSSIBLE. ALL
RIGHT. WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER SIX REDUCTIONS TO
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM.
WELCOME BACK. WHEN THE TIME
COMES, YOU'LL NEED TO REITERATE
YOUR NAME AND TITLE AGAIN AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. PLEASE
PROCEED. MAYOR HUXMAN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A $250 MILLION
REVERSION FOR THE MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM. THE
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM OFFERS LOW INTEREST
LONG-TERM DEFERRED PAYMENT LOANS
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION,
REHABILITATION AND PRESERVATION
OF PERMANENT AND TRANSITIONAL
RENTAL HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THE 2022 BUDGET
INCLUDED THREE $125 MILLION
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS IN
THE 2023 BUDGET INCLUDED AN
ADDITIONAL MILLION, AND 23 AND
24 FOR A TOTAL INVESTMENT OF
█425 MILLION OVER TWO YEARS. UH,
IN THIS PROPOSAL 100 AND 75
MILLION GENERAL FUND, OR 39%
REMAINS FOR THIS PROGRAM. ALL
RIGHT, THAT CONCLUDES A L.
NOTHING TO ADD. ARE THERE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE SUBCOMITTEE ON ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. STATE YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD. PLEASE LEND ME YOUR
COMMENTS TO A MINUTE. HEALTH AND
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. I JUST WANT
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM IS
THE DEPARTMENT'S CORE RENTAL
HOUSING FINANCE PROGRAM. IT'S
FLEXIBLE. IT CAN SERVE VARIOUS
NEEDS. IT CAN SERVE ALL
POPULATIONS, AND IT'S THOSE
CRITICAL RESOURCES THAT ALONG
WITH THE STATE TA TAX CREDITS
ALLOW US TO DRAW DOWN THOSE
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS THAT ARE
FREE FOR THE TAKING TO THE STATE
AND ABOUT A 1 TO 1 LEVEL. SO OF
ALL THE CUTS PROPOSED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. WE ARE MOST
INTERESTED IN OPPOSING THE CUTS
TO THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JULIE SNYDER AGAIN WITH
M Tð èC A BAG. UM, THIS WAS THE
LAST TIME YOU'LL HEAR FROM ME
TODAY. UM BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE THE REMARKS THAT WE WOULD
ALSO SAY FOR THE INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM AND
THE FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
PREVENTION PROGRAM AS WELL, I
THINK THEY'RE ALL THE SAME FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE. THESE FUNDS AND
THE GETS, I THINK TO SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS IS COMMENTS.
THESE FUNDS ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
OUR LOCALITIES TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT GOALS
. UM, AND WHILE WE MIGHT HAVE
SIGNED CONTRACTS MIGHT NOT HAVE
SIGNED CONTRACTS ON THESE FUNDS.
WE CERTAINLY ARE ANTICIPATING
THE STATE STICKING WITH THOSE
COMMITMENTS IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
HOUSING ELEMENT GOALS WE HAVE IN
THE BAY AREA A PRODUCTION
PIPELINE RIGHT NOW IN PRE
DEVELOPMENT OF MORE THAN 44,000
AFFORDABLE HOMES THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED WAITING ONLY FOR
SUBSIDY, UH, THAT GAPS ABOUT
$7.6 BILLION IN GROWING AND
THESE FUNDS ARE CRUCIAL TO HELP
US FILL THAT. SO, PLEASE, UM,
CONSIDER THIS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS PROGRAM, YOU LOOK AT I YOU
LOOK AT THE FORECLOSURE
PREVENTION, UM, PRESERVATION
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
PRESENT LIKE TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
SIX. WELCOME STATE. YOUR NAME.
WE HAVE A MINUTE. MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSING AND
CONSORTIUM, ALL HOME AND
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
ENTERPRISE JUST ACTUALLY HAS A
REPORT THAT THEY WILL BE ISSUING
LATER THIS WEEK THAT ACTUALLY
QUANTIFY SOME OF THE CUTS AND
THE IMPACT THAT IT WILL ACTUALLY
HAVE TO THE UNITS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PRODUCTION
PIPELINE. SO GOING BACK TO WHAT
SENATOR MABU PUVA WAS TALKING
ABOUT. RIGHT NOW, THERE'S ABOUT
50,000 UNITS THAT HAVE GONE ARE
IN THE PIPELINE HAVE ACTUALLY
SPENT MONEY TO DO ENTITLEMENTS
AND WE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
LOSE THEM. IF ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IS NOT PROVIDED THROUGH THE LATE
èC PROGRAM, AND MP, SO THESE
ARE REALLY CRITICAL DOLLARS. WE
HAVE REAL DATA THAT WE CAN NOW
SHARE WITH THE LEGISLATURE, AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO UPDATING YOU
NEXT NEXT WEEK ABOUT IT. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY ELSE? ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE BACK TO THE SUBCOMITTEE.
ALL THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD.
WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM SEVEN
REDUCTIONS IN THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT I PROGRAM
PLEASE PROCEED. BLAIR HUXMAN,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
$200 MILLION REVERSION FOR THE
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM. THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDES GAP FUNDING TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND DEVELOPERS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
HIGHER DENSITY, AFFORDABLE AND
MIXED INCOME, HOUSING AND
LOCATIONS DESIGNATED AS INFILL.
THE 2022 BUDGET INCLUDED 425
MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
YEARS. AND WITH THIS PROPOSAL,
225 MILLION GENERAL FUND, OR 50,
3% REMAINS FOR THIS PROGRAM.
QLAL. JENNY BELLO WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT IT ALSO MEANS THAT
THERE'S ABOUT 25 MILLION
AVAILABLE FOR I THAT HAS NOT
ALREADY BEEN OUT FOR A WORD. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, UH, ANYONE
FROM? UH, THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THIS ISSUE SPECIFICALLY ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. SIGNAL AND WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GETTING INTO
TERRITORY WHERE WE'RE TALKING
HYPOTHETICALLY ABOUT BOND
PROCEEDS, AND YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
PERSPECTIVE, AND IT'S A LITTLE
NERVE WRACKING. GIVEN THE
PARTICULAR IMPACT OF SOME OF
THESE PROPOSED CUTS. I'LL JUST
NOTE THAT FOR THE RECORD,
SENATOR NILO ALL RIGHT. THIS
ITEM IS ALSO HELD. WE'LL MOVE TO
ISSUE A REDUCTIONS TO CALHOUN
PROGRAM. PLEASE PROCEED. HUXMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S INCLUDES 100 AND
$52.5 MILLION GENERAL FUND
REVERSION FOR CALHOUN. CALHOUN
PROVIDES GRANTS TO LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND NONPROFIT
CORPORATIONS FOR FIRST TIME HOME
BUYER AND HOUSING,
REHABILITATION ASSISTANCE, HOME
BUYER COUNSELING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACTIVITIES. THE 2022
BUDGET INCLUDED $350 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS AND
THE 2020 THREE BUDGET REDUCED
2023 24. FUNDING BY $50 MILLION,
LEAVING THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR THE
PROGRAM AT 300 MILLION. WITH
THIS PROPOSAL, 100 AND 47.5
MILLION GENERAL FUND OR
APPROXIMATELY 49% REMAINS FOR
THIS PROGRAM. I AM. NOTHING TO
ADD. ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMITTEE.
ON ISSUE EIGHT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. WE'LL MOVE TO ISSUE NINE
REDUCTIONS IN THE VETERANS,
HOUSING AND HOMELESS PREVENTION
PROGRAMS. AN ISSUE. SEVEN WILL
BE HELD OPEN. PLEASE PROCEED.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
$50 MILLION GENERAL FUNDER
VERSION FOR THE VETERANS HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
PROGRAM. THE VETERANS HOUSING
AND HOMELESS PREVENTION PROGRAM
PROVIDES LONG-TERM LOANS FOR THE
ACQUISITION, CONSTRUCTION,
REHABILITATION AND PRESERVATION
OF AFFORDABLE MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING FOR VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE 2022 BUDGET
INCLUDED 100 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND OVER TWO YEARS, AND THAT'S
50 MILLION EACH IN 2022 20,
THREE AND 2020, THREE 24. AND
WITH THIS PROPOSAL, 50 MILLION
GENERAL FUND OR ABOUT 50%
REMAINS FOR THIS PROGRAM.
EARLIER. ADDITIONAL THANK YOU.
ARE THERE MEMBERS IN THE HEARING
ROOM LIKE TO ADDRESS SUB
COMMITTEE ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD, AND YOUR
TIME IS LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU. UM, I'D ACTUALLY LIKE
TO COMMENT ON ISSUE EIGHT. IF
THAT'S OK. UM I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
CALIFORNIA UM, ON BEHALF OF THE
33 AFFILIATES ON THE REVERSION
OF THE CALHOUN FUNDING. UM, WE
JUST LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT ABOUT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE CUT, ESPECIALLY
IN COMPARISON TO RENTAL. UM,
IT'S THE ONLY PROGRAM HERE
THAT'S TAILORED TOWARDS
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THE STATE
BUDGET, SO IT WILL BE HELPING
OUR LOW INCOME MINORITY
COMMUNITIES BUILD OUT THAT
GENERATIONAL WEALTH FOR DECADES
AND DECADES TO COME. UM WE'RE
LOOKING AT UP TO 2000 UNITS
BEING LEFT UNBUILT IN THE STATE.
IF THIS PROGRAM IS, IN FACT
REVERTED 50 THREE MILLION OF
WHICH IS BEING PUT TO WORK BY
OUR HABITAT AFFILIATES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING. ANYBODY ELSE? ALL
RIGHT. WE GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I THINK LET'S
PLEASE PROCEED TO ISSUE UH,
NUMBER 10. HAVING THIS RIGHT?
IT'S ALL RIGHT. MOVING ALONG.
PLEASE PROCEED. HUXMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES $13.7
MILLION IN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS FOR HOUSING
NAVIGATORS. THESE FUNDS ARE USED
FOR GRANTS TO COUNTIES BASED ON
EACH COUNTY'S PERCENTAGE OF THE
TOTAL STATEWIDE NUMBER OF YOUNG
ADULTS AGED 18 TO 24 AND FOSTER
CARE OR IN PROBATION SYSTEMS.
THE 2022 BUDGET INCLUDED $13.7
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND ONGOING
TO SUPPLEMENT COUNTY FUNDING FOR
HOUSING NAVIGATORS TO ASSIST
FORMALLY FOSTER YOUTH. EARLIER.
I THINK ADDITIONAL TO ADD. WE
DID NOTICE THE QUESTION IN THE
AGENDA THAT SUGGESTED THAT, UH,
WE WERE ASKED WHETHER OR NOT THE
FUNDING WAS USED TO DRAW DOWN
THE VOUCHERS. AND IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING. UH, FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THAT SOME OF THIS
FUNDING CAN BE USED FOR THE CASE
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT TO SECURE
THOSE VOUCHERS. ARE THERE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMITTEE
ON ISSUE NUMBER 10? HØI PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR TIME
WILL BE LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE TO
YOU. THANK YOU. I AM FROM BUTTE
COUNTY, AND I AM A LOCAL FOSTER
YOUTH. THIS FUNDING HAS HELPED
MANY FOSTER YOUTH IN OUR COUNTY
STAY HOME AND STAY OFF THE
STREETS. BUTTE COUNTY HAS A HUGE
PROBLEM WITH HOMELESSNESS. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS FUNDING WILL
HELP KEEP YOUTH OFF THE STREET.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER VASQUEZ. AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF LUTHERAN
SOCIAL SERVICES AS A HOUSING AND
NAVIGATION CASE MANAGER. I ASKED
THE COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE
FUNDING FOR THE $13.7 MILLION
HOUSING NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM, WHICH IS
PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE TO BE
ELIMINATED AS A PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM AND DIFFERENT AGENCIES
COME TOGETHER TO SERVE OVER 1300
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH, WITH
FEDERAL HOUSING VOUCHERS KEEPING
YOUTH HOUSE WHILE LEVERAGING 32
MILLION IN FEDERAL HOUSING
ASSISTANCE. THIS PROGRAM, LIKE
MANY OTHER HOUSING AND
NAVIGATION PROGRAMS, TEACH YOUTH
HOW TO BECOME A GOOD TENANT,
NAVIGATE EXISTING BARRIERS AND
GIVE THIS YOUTH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FIND A HOME. I ASK YOU TODAY
TO HELP WITH US AND SERVE THESE
YOUTH TO OBTAIN THEIR OWN
HOUSING BY PRESERVING THESE
FUNDS FOR THIS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
WEDNESDAY. POPE AND I'M A
CURRENT. UH, WELL, SORRY,
CURRENT FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE
STUDENT AND A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA. UM I AM
HERE TO REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PRESERVE FUNDING FOR
THE HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM IN THE STATE
BUDGET. WHEN I EXITED FOSTER
CARE UPON TURNING 21, I HAD NÓ
HOUSING OPTIONS. I HAD NÓ FAMILY
I COULD STAY WITH AND CERTAINLY
COULD NOT AFFORD TO RENT MY OWN
APARTMENT. MOST APARTMENTS
REQUIRE THE THREE TIMES THE
MONTHLY RENTAL INCOME AND EVEN
WITH A JOB AND FINANCIAL AID
FROM SCHOOL, I COULD NOT AFFORD
THIS. THE HOUSING, NAVIGATION
AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. BOTH
INCREASES COMMUNITIES ACCESS TO
SEEKING HOUSING. OH, EXCUSE ME.
HOUSING VOUCHERS FROM FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND FUNDS
THAT SUPPORT YOUTH RECEIVE WITH
TURNING THEIR VOUCHER INTO
ACTUAL HOUSING. IF THE 13.7
MILLION STATE FUNDED HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM AND THE 22 MILLION IN
FEDERAL VOUCHERS IT LEVERAGES
WERE AVAILABLE. WHEN I EXITED
CARE, I LIKELY WOULD NOT HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS, PLEASE
PROVE THE PRESERVE THE HOUSING
NAVIGATION MAINTENANCE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HØI MY
NAME IS ROSELLA WHEEL AND I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH I USED TO
ATTEND AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE.
I'M HERE TO REQUEST A
LEGISLATIVE PRESERVE FUNDING FOR
THE HOUSING NAVIGATION
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM IN THIS
BUDGET. YOU. HØI UM MY NAME IS
TUNISIA. JONES AND I AM A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. UM I ATTEND
SACRAMENTO STATE CURRENTLY, UM I
HAVE EXPERIENCED THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM FOR 13 YEARS OF MY LIFE,
UM, WITH NÓ SUPPORT SYSTEM. I
HAVE SEEN THE BENEFIT OF THIS
PROGRAM, UH, PROVIDING HOUSING
VOUCHERS TO KEEP FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH LIKE ME FROM BEING
HOMELESS. I AM ASKING THE
COMMITTEE TODAY TO PRESERVE 13.7
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING. UM OF
THE HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM THAT FACES
ELIMINATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
SIMONE TERK. LEE. I'M HERE WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING A
COALITION OF MORE THAN 100,
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE AND OVER
200 YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE ALSO
JOINED OUR COALITION A LITTLE
SHORT OF THIS DOWN. UM I'M HERE.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING THAT YOU
PRESERVE THE $13.7 MILLION
HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM AND CONTINUE
TO STAND WITH FOSTER YOUTH. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE THE SENATE'S SUPPORT
OVER THE YEARS. KNOW THAT YOU
RECOGNIZE THE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION AND APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS A SMALL STATE PROGRAM
THAT PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
HELPING US ACCESS $22 MILLION IN
FEDERAL HOUSING ASSISTANCE FROM
HUD VIA HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHERS
THAT ARE SPECIAL POPULATION
VOUCHERS. AND THIS IS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE COMING FROM THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM DO NOT HAVE FAMILY
SUPPORT CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPETITIVE HOUSING MARKETS IN
THE COUNTRY. WE HAVE THE LARGEST
FOSTER CARE POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY, ALSO LARGE HOMELESS
YOUTH POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT PASS ON THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING AND THE SIZE OF
THE STATE FUNDING RELATIVE TO
WHAT WE CAN GET FEDERALLY, I
SAY, REALLY, THE MATH MATHS OUT
THERE, UM, IN TERMS OF US
SUSTAINING THAT IN THE BUDGET,
MY LAST THING I'LL SHARE BEFORE
I LEAVE. IS THAT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AS A YOUNG PERSON
IS THE MOST COMMON PATHWAY TO
CHRONIC ADULT HOMELESSNESS,
WHICH I KNOW HAS BEEN A PRIORITY
FOR THE GOVERNOR. THE
LEGISLATURE CITIZENS, UM FOR
SOME YEARS NOW, AND THIS IS OUR
EVIDENCE BASED SOLUTION TO
PREVENTING CHRONIC ADULT
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS. MARTHA GUERRERO,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
REDUCTION AS YOU HEARD FROM JB
HOW CRITICAL THIS FUNDING IS FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, AND, UM, WE URGE
THAT YOU REJECT THE PROPOSED CUT
, AND, UM, THANK THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DELEGATION. UM THE
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION WHO
SIGNED ON IN PRESERVING, UM THIS
FUNDING. THANK YOU. HØI JENNY
CHOI WITH UM CALIFORNIA
COLLISION FOR YOUTH. WEINER
COMMENT WITH OTHERS URGING YOU
TO CONSIDER REJECTING THIS CUT
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
THE WRITE UP ON JEOPARDIZING
FEDERAL FUNDS. THANK YOU. HØI.
MY NAME IS KHALIL VILLIUS, AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF BUTTE
COLLEGE, UM, TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE FUNDING TO
THE $13.7 MILLION HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS PROPOSED TO
ELIMINATE IN THE GOV. GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THIS PROGRAM SERVES OVER
1300 FOSTER. FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WITH FEDERAL HOUSING VOUCHERS,
KEEPING YOUTH HOUSED WHILE
LEVERAGING 22 MILLION IN FEDERAL
HOUSING ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS KAI
BUCKLES. AND I'M HERE WITH, UH
BUTTE COLLEGE AND INSPIRING
SCHOLARS. UM I'M HERE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE THE
FUNDING FOR THE $13.7 MILLION
HOUSING AND NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. WHICH IS
PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, AND THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT IS HEAVILY NEEDED
IN BUTE COUNTY FOR UH, CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSSIL YOUTH. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA
KATIE AND AS A FORMERLY HOMELESS
FOSTER YOUTH MYSELF, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO NOT
REFORM THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM, AS IT HAS ALREADY SHOWN
TO STRUGGLE WITH ITS OFFENSIVELY
SMALL BUDGET AND WOULD ONLY
SERVE AS A DETRIMENTAL FOSTER
YOUTH AGING OUT OF THE PROGRAM,
DECREASING THE BUDGETING FOR
HOUSING NAVIGATION IN S¼, ONLY
HER AGING OUT FOSTER CHILDREN AS
THEY WITH THE SUPPORT OF THIS
PROGRAM HAVE ALREADY SHOWN THAT
THEY ARE STILL STRUGGLING
EXTRANEOUSLY TO SURVIVE AND
DESPERATELY NEED ANY ASSISTANCE
THEY CAN RECEIVE. THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M UH, COMING ON BEHALF
OF LUTHERAN SOCIAL SERVICES AS A
CASE MANAGER FOR YOUTH
CONNECTIONS, AGES 18 TO 24
YOUTH. UM I HEARD THIS COMMITTEE
TO RECONSIDER THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THIS PROGRAM WITH IS
$13.7 MILLION FUNDING IS A
LIFELINE FOR OVER 1300 FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH, PROVIDING THEM
WITH FEDERAL HOUSING VOUCHERS
AND LEVERAGING $22 MILLION IN
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT KEEPING A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS, IT'S ABOUT
PROVIDING STABILITY AND HOPE FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE FACED
UNIMAGINABLE CHALLENGES BY
PRESERVING FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. WE ARE NOT JUST
INVESTING IN HOUSING. WE ARE
INVESTING IN THE POTENTIAL OF
OUR YOU TO BECOME ADVOCATES,
MENTORS AND LEADERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. HELLO
CHAIR MEMBERS. UH, MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ. I'M A
FORMER FOSS YOUTH AS WELL AS
LEAD THE LEGISLATIVE DEPARTMENT
AT CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION SAYS
NOT THESE CUTS. NOT THESE KIDS.
THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE
SUFFERING FROM HOMELESSNESS, AND
THEY NEED A PLACE TO STAY. SO WE
ASKED TODAY THAT YOU PLEASE
PRESERVE THE HOUSING AND
NAVIGATION MAINTENANCE FUNDING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
I'M GINA. I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. AND I AM HERE TO I'M
SORRY. I'M NERVOUS. UM DOING
GREAT. THANK YOU FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM. IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. UM A LOT OF
FOSTER KIDS THAT ARE IN THE
SYSTEM DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
TOOLS ONCE THEY AGE OUT OF IT IN
THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THAT. THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
ELLA HOMAN BURSE AND I AM THE
SUPERVISOR FOR THE HOUSING
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM IN STOCKTON
AND I GET TO GET UP EVERY DAY AS
YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD FROM THEM TO
ASSIST THEM IN THEIR LIVING
FAITH. THEY'VE EXPRESSED HOW
IMPORTANT THE FUNDS ARE AND HOW
IT HELPS THEM NAVIGATE. SO THE
PROGRAM HELPS THEM EACH DAY.
GIVE THEM HOPE TO CONTINUE ON
ANOTHER DAY, SO WE JUST ASK YOU
TO KEEP THOSE FUNDS IN THE
BUDGET AS BEST AS POSSIBLE. YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS BRIANNA VAUGHAN. I'M
A FORMER, UM FOSTER YOUTH, AND
I'M ALSO A FULL TIME NURSING
STUDENT AT BUTTE COLLEGE. I
RESPECTIVELY URGE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATOR TO PRESERVE THE
HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AS FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. I HAVE FIRSTHAND
EXPERIENCE AT HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS AFTER AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM
, ESPECIALLY WHILE CARING FOR MY
LITTLE BROTHER, WHO WAS ALSO IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND
RAISING MY OWN DAUGHTER. THIS
PROGRAM IS A BEACON OF HOPE AND
STABILITY FOR ALL FOSTER YOUTH
LIKE US ST STRIVING TO BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE FOR OURSELVES AND
OUR FAMILIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. YOU. HØI. I'M JASMINE.
TERRY I'M HERE FOR HONOR
REPRESENTING, BUT COLLEGE. I'M
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE KIDS IN YOUR
PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO,
LIKE. SHUT DOWN RIGHT NOW. I
URGE YOU TO NOT DO THAT, BECAUSE
IT HELPS ME OUT A LOT. IF I
DIDN'T HAVE THIS PROGRAM, I
WOULD HONESTLY BE ON THE STREETS
DOING DRUGS LIKE HOW MY FAMILY
ALWAYS DID. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS DESIREE PATTERSON. UM
I'M HERE, UH, TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
I'M A GUARDIAN SCHOLAR AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY. UM
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT OR TO
PRESERVE THE FUNDS FOR, UM, THE
HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. I'M SO
SORRY. I'M NERVOUS. UM, AND I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT A
LOT OF, UH YOUNG WOMEN WHO EXIT
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM, UM,
RESORT TO LIVING WITH THEIR
SIGNIFICANT OTHER AND ARE AT
RISK OF DAMASK DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THEY ONLY OPTIONS ARE TO
HAVE HOUSING WITH SOMEONE ELSE
OR TO GO HOMELESS. AND I JUST
WANNA POINT OUT THAT THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. BE PATIENT
WITH ME. I AM NERVOUS AS WELL.
UM I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
LUTHERAN SOCIAL SERVICES. I WAS
ACTUALLY A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
I AM NOW A HOUSING NAVIGATION
CASE MANAGER. UM SO I REALLY
FEEL LIKE I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE TABLES THAT CAN BE
TURNED AROUND THE STEREOTYPE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. UM WE ARE ACTIVELY
ACHIEVING REDUCING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGH USING VOUCHERS. UH, FY I
IN HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
INCLUDED. UM I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT FOSTER YOUTH ARE AT, UM
EXCUSE ME. HOLD ON. YOU'RE DOING
GREAT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE, UM
MORE RISK FOR IMMINENT DANGER
JUST BECAUSE WE ARE EXPOSED TO
MORE VIOLENT AND DRUG RELATED
CRIMES, UM, DUE TO SIGNIFICANT
RELOCATION THROUGH GROUP HOMES
AND FOSTER PLACEMENTS IF YOU ARE
LUCKY TO BE PLACED IN A FOSTER
HOME, UM WHICH AGAIN YOU ARE
SUBJECTED TO AMOUNTS OF ABUSE IN
THOSE HOMES AS WELL. UM WE
OFTENTIMES ARE ENTERING THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO BY
THE TIME THAT WE ARE ADULTS AND
WE ARE READY TO PREPARE
OURSELVES FOR ADULTHOOD WE ARE
ALREADY LOSING OUT ON CHANCES,
AND WE ALREADY HAVE A STEREOTYPE
SURROUNDING US. UM WE OFTEN LACK
THE ABILITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OURSELVES ON CREDIT BUILDING. UM
A 167 WAS PUT INTO PLACE FOR US
TO PRESERVE OUR RIGHT TO BE ABLE
TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL BECAUSE
DUE TO RELOCATING THROUGH GROUP
GROUP HOMES AND FOSTER
PLACEMENTS, WE OFTEN UM DO NOT
GET TO COMPLETE OUR DIPLOMAS OR
WE LOSE MOTIVATION TO, UM IT IS
FROM THE DEEPEST PART OF MY
HEART FOR MYSELF AND MY
COMMUNITY TODAY THAT YOU PLEASE
PRESERVE THIS FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. UM LIKE I SAID BEFORE,
THIS WAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO AND GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JESSICA FUENTES AND I AM
A LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE MEMBER.
UM FROM THE BAY AREA WITH
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION. I'M
HERE TO SAY NOT THESE CUTS, NOT
THESE KIDS. AS A FOSTER YOUTH
WHO WAS HOMELESS. HAVING ACCESS
TO THESE RESOURCES, HELP YOUTH
BECOME SUCCESSFUL AND THRIVING
ADULTS TODAY AS I GRADUATED
AIRCRAFT MECHANIC ARE PROOF THAT
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES ALLOW
US TO BECOME TO NOT BECOME A
PART OF THE STATISTICS THAT ARE
USUALLY GIVEN TO FOSSIL YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WELCOME TO THOSE IN LINE AND
JOINING US JUST A FRIENDLY
REMINDER. WE COME FORWARD STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD AND
LIMIT YOUR TIME TO ONE MINUTE,
PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WELCOME. HELLO MY NAME IS
ETERNITY. HERNANDEZ I'M A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. AND I'M HERE TO
JUST LET YOU GUYS KNOW HOW MUCH,
UH, S¼ S¼ HOUSING NAVIGATION
PROGRAM HAS HELPED ME OUT. IT
HAS KEPT ME OUT OF SEX
TRAFFICKING. UM IT HAS GIVEN ME
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A HOME FOR
ADDRESS TO HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET A JOB AND TO HELP ME ALSO
HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO BE
ABLE TO PAY OFF COLLEGE AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YEAH. NÓ.
UM YES, HØI. MY NAME IS DEREK
CLARK. I'M FROM BILL WILSON
CENTER. I AM THE CHIEF PROGRAM
OFFICER. AND SO I. I WANTED TO
JUST MENTION THE DAY THEY WERE.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
MENTIONED AS AS YOU ALREADY KNOW
, WE'RE WE'RE IN A HOUSING
CRISIS, RIGHT? LIKE AS FAR AS
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. WE ARE THE
LARGEST IN THE ACTUAL NATION.
AND SO THAT 13.7 MILLION THAT
HAS BEEN APPROVED HAS HAS REALLY
STARTED TO HELP ON HELPING US
IDENTIFYING HOUSING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE. IF THAT IF FUNDING GOES
AWAY THE PICTURE THAT WE'RE ALL
GOING TO LOOK AT. IS THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE ENDING BACK UP AT PLACES
LIKE BILL CENTER IN OUR HOMELESS
SHELTER? UM WE'RE GONNA SEE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE OUT ON THE
STREET BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY CERTAIN TYPE
OF HOUSING. YES WE WILL PROVIDE
CASE MANAGEMENT, BUT WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO HOUSE WE WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP WITH EMPLOYMENT,
BUT THEY WILL LOSE THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NÓ PLACE TO
LIVE. SO THESE FUNDS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AS FAR AS US BALING
THIS HOUSING CRISIS, SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THIS
IS KIND OF UP HERE. FEEL FREE TO
PUSH IT DOWN IF IT IS BENEFICIAL
TO YOU. UH YOU YOU CAN PULL.
PULL IT DOWN. THANKS. THANKS FOR
THE ASSIST. THERE YOU GO. HELLO
I'M JACKSON AND I'M HERE WITH
INSPIRING SCHOLARS IN CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION. I BELIEVE THAT
HOUSING MANAGEMENT AND
NAVIGATION PROGRAM IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS SOMEONE WHO
IS LEAVING, UH, TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAMS SOON AND I'VE
BEEN ACCEPTED TO RECEIVE AN FY I
VOUCHER THANKS TO THE  N HÌ M  N
P PROGRAM. THE HM MP PROGRAM HAS
BEEN ABLE TO HELP WITH HOUSING.
I HAVE A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY STUNNING. THAT
HM AND P PROGRAM IS ALSO WORKING
ON PROVIDING FOSTER YOUTH SUCH
AS MYSELF WITH HOUSING VOUCHERS
THAT WILL ASSIST WITH HELPING ME
PAY TO KEEP THIS NICE APARTMENT
BECAUSE IT'S A NICE APARTMENT. I
COULD PERSONALLY CONFIRM THAT
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS ME TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL STUDENT, A LEADER AND
AN ADVOCATOR FOR PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND HAVE HOPE FOR MY
FUTURE. WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM, I
AM PRONE TO HOMELESSNESS. AND IF
THIS HAPPENS, I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE BEING SUCCESSFUL.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 50 PEOPLE.
IN BUTTE COUNTY WHO ARE ON THE
WAIT LIST FOR FYR VOUCHERS, AND
THEY DESERVE HOUSING, STABILITY
AND ASSISTANCE AS MUCH AS ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HØI MY NAME IS PARKER AND I
EXPERIENCED THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. I AM A STUDENT AT BUTE
COLLEGE STUDYING FOR NURSING.
I'M HERE TO ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESERVE FUNDING FOR THE $13.7
MILLION HOUSING NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM, WHICH IS
PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS PROGRAM
SERVES OVER 1300 FORMER FOSSIL
YOUTH WITH FEDERAL HOUSING
VOUCHERS KEEPING YOU HOUSE WHILE
LEVERAGING 22 MILLION IN FEDERAL
HOUSING ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HØI THERE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. MY NAME IS VANCE
EDWARDS. I'M FROM BUT COLLEGE
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
HOUSING, UH, NAVIGATION PROGRAM.
IT SUPPORTS STUDENTS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY AT AGE 21, SOME OF
THEM ARE NOT READY TO BE
TRANSITIONED FULLY TO
INDEPENDENCE. AND UH, FACE
HOMELESSNESS IN BUT COUNTY. UM
AND SO HER REQUEST IS THAT YOU
PRESERVE THAT FUNDING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. AND JUST BRIEFLY PAUSE.
SERGEANT AT ARMS. WHAT'S THE
QUEUE? LOOK LIKE OUT THERE. ALL
RIGHT, SIR. THANK YOU. AND
WELCOME EVERYONE. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD YOUR
TIME. BE LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE.
HØI EVERYONE. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
JENNY ESPINOZA. AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT BACK TO
THE START TO ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO PRESERVE FUNDING FOR THE
$13.7 MILLION HOUSING NAVIGATION
AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAM, WHICH
IS PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OUR
ORGANIZATION WORKS WITH
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM TO HELP
THEM PROCESS AND WRITE ABOUT
THEIR CHILDHOOD TRAUMAS AS A
MEANS OF HEALING AND GROWTH, AS
WELL AS TO RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS ABOUT HOW TO DISRUPT
THE CRADLE TO PRISON PIPELINE
WILL WORK. WE HAVE HEARD MANY
POWERFUL STORIES FROM
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES IN THE FOSTER
SYSTEM AT INFLECTION POINTS IN
THEIR LIVES, INCLUDING A STARK
CHOICES THEY'VE HAD TO MAKE
AROUND. BINDING AND AFFORDING
HOUSING AS A TRANSITION FROM THE
FOSTER SYSTEM. SOME COUNTED HOW
THEY WERE FACED WITH THIS CHOICE
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS AND
RETURNING TO A VIOLENT HOME
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THEIR
FRIENDS AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
WERE KILLED DUE TO GUN VIOLENCE
OR DRUG VIOLENCE. SINCE THE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
PARTICIPANTS CAN'T BE HERE ON
THEIR BEHALF. WE ARE PASSING
ALONG THE FOLLOWING MESSAGE.
WE'VE ONLY GOT ONE SHOT TO GET
THIS RIGHT FOR THESE KIDS. IT'S
LIFE OR DEATH. FOR MANY. THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS WHERE YOU
DON'T WANNA FAIL THEM SO THAT
HOPEFULLY THEY DON'T END UP. WE
ARE IN PRISON OR EVEN WORSE. WE
WILL NOT JUST LOOKING AT THE
BUDGET. WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
LIVES OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
YOUTH. THANK YOU. OK? I REMEMBER
THE MIC IS VERY SENSITIVE. SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GET ON TOP OF
IT. THERE YOU GO. THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS JAN JUDSON. I AM A CO FOUNDER
AND BOARD PRESIDENT FOR A
NONPROFIT IN YELLOW COUNTY
CALLED MAKE IT HAPPEN FOR YOLO
COUNTY. WE PROVIDE HOUSEHOLD
FURNITURE AND ITEMS FOR
TRANSITION. AGE USE LARGELY
YOUTH FROM 16 TO 24. THEY'RE
MOVING OUT OF FOSTER CARE INTO
INDEPENDENT LIVING. WE ARE HERE
ALSO TO SUPPORT THE HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. CONTINUATION WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING RIGHT NOW WITH
THE YOUTH WHO WILL AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE NEXT MONTH AT AGE 21
, AND SHE IS DESPERATE TO FIND
HOUSING HAS BEEN LOOKING BUT
DOESN'T HAVE A CREDIT RATING. UM
SO WE'RE RELYING A LOT ON
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURSELVES TO HELP WITH GETTING
SECURITY DEPOSITS. ALL THAT, BUT
IT'S JUST A PERSISTENT ISSUE AND
TAKING THIS AWAY WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. I APPRECIATE IT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS EMERALD
EVANS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY,
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH, AND I WANT TO ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE THE
FUNDING FOR THE HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM THAT IS PROPOSED TO BE
ELIMINATED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THIS IS A CRITICAL
PROGRAM THAT'S SERVING OVER 1000
THREE 100 FOSTER YOUTH, UM, TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE HOUSED, BUT
NOT ONLY HOUSED BUT ARE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN HOUSING. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
PURVA BCHAR. I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHAD AND FAMILY
SERVICES WE REPRESENT OVER 100
AND 65 DIFFERENT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND I'M
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF
PRESERVING THE FUNDING FOR THE
HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM THEY USE
HOUSING VOUCHERS ARE CRUCIAL TO
OUR TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
POPULATION, AND WE BELIEVE THAT
YOU KNOW, THIS IS JUST A
PREVENTATIVE MEASURE TO SOLVE OR
HELP MAINTAIN THE CURRENT YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. 40% OF THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION CONSIST
OF FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
CUTTING THESE SERVICES. CUTTING
THESE PROGRAMS WILL JUST COST
THE STATE SO MUCH MORE IN THE
INTERIM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. SUSANNA AND IF I'M
WITH CHILDREN, NOW HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM YOU. KEN REX ROAD WITH
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CAREGIVERS, ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
AM VALERIE HARTLEY, AND I'M THE
SUPERVISOR FOR THE HÌ AND P
PROGRAM IN SHASTA COUNTY. AND
I'M ASKING YOU NOT TO, UM, CUT
ANY FUNDS. THIS PROGRAM HAS
REMOVED SO MANY BARRIERS FOR OUR
YOUTH TO NOT BE HOMELESS OR
REMOVE BARRIERS. UM, SO THEY
COULD GET OUT OF THE HOMELESS
SITUATION. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
MERCEDES PARKER WITH, UH,
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL OF OUR
STAFF AND MEMBERS ALREADY TODAY.
UM SO I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
NOT THESE CUTS, NOT THESE KIDS,
THE HOUSING MAINTENANCE AND
NAVIGATION PROGRAM ACROSS THE
STATE REPRESENTS ONE AREA OF
HOPE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. WE ARE IN
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND FOSTER
YOUTH ARE MORE SEVERELY IMPACTED
BY THAT ALMOST ANYBODY ELSE AND
SO WE WANNA PRESERVE. UM THAT
LIFE SUPPORT THAT LIFELINE FOR
THEM. AND SO I URGE YOU NOT TO
CUT THE $13 MILLION 13.7. DOLLAR
HOUSING MAINTENANCE AND
NAVIGATION PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. Dð èC LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM IN LOS ANGELES,
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT OF THE HOUSING
MAINTENANCE AND NAVIGATION
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS SUB-COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATION. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. IS THERE
A CONSENSUS? THAT INPUT THAT, IN
FACT, THERE'S A POTENTIAL TO
LOSE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL VOUCHER FUNDS. IF IN
FACT WE TOOK UP THE
RECOMMENDATION. FEEL FREE TO
RESPOND. YOU KNOW, ANDREW MARS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO, UM
ALTHOUGH SOME STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
NOTED, AND THIS AND WITNESSES
TODAY THAT SOME OF THE FUNDING
IS USED TO, UH, SUPPORT THE
REQUIRED ACTIVITIES FOR VARIOUS
FOSTER YOUTH HOUSING VOUCHERS,
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY REQUIREMENT
OF THE FUNDING. THE FUNDING IS
VERY FLEXIBLE IN WHAT IT CAN
PROVIDE IN SOME COUNTIES HAVE
CHOSEN TO UTILIZE THE FUNDING
FOR THAT. I? I'D ALSO NOTE THAT
THIS ISN'T THE ONLY SOURCE OF
FUNDING THAT COUNTIES CAN USE
FOR THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY. UM
THERE IS EXISTING ONGOING
FUNDING THAT COUNTIES RECEIVE
FROM THE BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS
TRUST FUND THAT THEY CAN
REDIRECT OR UTILIZE. FOR THIS.
IT'S A FLEXIBLE POT OF FUNDING
THAT COUNTIES CAN USE AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S THE
HOMELESS HOUSING AND, UM AND
PREVENTION. THE HAP FUNDING THAT
CAN ALSO BE USED FOR HOUSING,
NAVIGATION SO AND I WOULD LOOK
AT THIS PROGRAM IN CONCERT WITH,
UM, THE PROGRAM THAT'S NOTED ON
THE AGENDA. THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLUS HOUSING SUPPLEMENT
PROGRAM, WHICH RECEIVES 42 POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR, SO
YOU HAVE 42.3 MILLION AND $13.7
MILLION, AND THAT 42 POINT THREE
MILLION IS MAINTAINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THANK YOU,
ANTHONY, SENATOR NILO. UM, A
QUESTION. THIS IS NOT A HOUSING
PROGRAM IN THE SENSE OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WERE
CONSIDERING IT. IT'S REALLY A
SAFETY NET. FOSTER CARE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WOULD SEEM TO
BE MORE APPROPRIATELY CONSIDERED
UNDER HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SERVICES. SO I I'D LIKE TO SEE
WHAT THE VARIOUS STAFF MEMBERS
HERE WOULD HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT. I DON'T PRETEND TO BE AN
EXPERT ON THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
, BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
DUE TO VARIOUS CONSTRAINTS OF
REALIGNMENT, THIS FUNDING WAS
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT SEVERAL
YEARS AGO ALONG WITH THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLUS
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT PROGRAM, UM,
DUE TO SOME OF THE CONSTRAINTS
WITH REALIGNMENT FUNDING. THE
FUNDS DON'T INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING, THOUGH IT PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE TO FOSTER YOUTH AGING
OUT FOSTER USE TO FIND IN
ACQUIRE HOUSING. YOU HAVE THAT
RIGHT? THAT'S THAT'S ONE. THAT'S
ONE. THAT'S ONE ACTIVITY THAT
COUNTIES CAN CHOOSE TO USE FOR
FUNDING THE PRO THAT OR USE THE
FUNDING FOR THAT. IT'S A VERY
FLEXIBLE FUNDING AND COUNTIES
CAN CAN USE IT. HOW THEY SEE FIT
WITHIN, UM, VARIOUS PARAMETERS,
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD, SOME
COUNTIES HAVE USED IT FOR THAT
PURPOSE. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FROM HDD ON THAT JENNIFER SEEGER
, DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF STATE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AT THE DEPARTMENT. SO
AS MY COLLEAGUE AT Dð Ó F
MENTIONED YES. THIS IS ONE OF
VARIOUS ELIGIBLE USES UNDER THE
PROGRAM TO YOUR POINT OF WHETHER
OR NOT IT ACTUALLY RESULTS IN
NEW UNITS. THERE ARE MAINTENANCE
TYPE ACTIVITIES, SO THERE ARE
HEALTH AND SAFETY KIND OF ISSUES
THAT ARE ADDRESSED THROUGH SOME
OF THESE PROGRAM FUNDS. IT'S OF
COURSE, DEPENDENT ON THE
ULTIMATE RECIPIENT OF THE FUNDS
AND HOW THEY CHOOSE. BUT UNDER
THE PROGRAM, THERE IS A WIDE
VARIE. ABUSES AS WE HAVE HEARD,
MANY OF THE COUNTIES CHOOSE TO
USE THEM FOR CASE MANAGEMENT AND
NAVIGATION PROGRAMS. I Ó. JENNY
BELLO WITH THE ANALYSTS OFFICE.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT, UH WE
ALSO I ACTUALLY WORK ON THE
HUMAN SERVICES ISSUES AS WELL
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE IS ON
OUR RADAR AS WE'RE CONSIDERING
THE OTHER REDUCTIONS PROPOSED ON
THE FOSTER CARE SIDE, SO IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE INTEND TO
BRING UP IN THOSE SUBCOMMITTEES
TOO, SIR, IS THAT SORT OF CROSS
LEARNING AND UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL? WERE CONSIDERING THIS IN
THE CONTEXT OF PRIORITIES,
CHOICES OF PRIORITIES FOR
FUNDING IN AN AREA THAT I DON'T
THINK IT'S COMPARABLE TO. I GET
THE POINT OF FLEXIBILITY, BUT
BASED UPON THE TESTIMONY AND I
THINK PROBABLY BASED UPON ACTUAL
EXECUTION OF THIS, IT IS LARGELY
A FOSTER CARE BENEFIT PROGRAM,
AND, UM PROBABLY SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THE CONTEXT OF
OTHER FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS. UM
SO, UH, IT'S JUST II I IT SEEMS
TO ME THIS IS MISCLASSIFIED AND
UNDER THE WRONG IN THE WRONG
AREA OF STATE GOVERNANCE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. FOR THAT. THIS
ITEM WILL ALSO BE HELD. I'LL
MAKE A NOTE FOR THE DOCKET.
TODAY I ISSUE NUMBER ONE UNDER
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FROM BOAT
ITEMS TO AN ITEM OF DISCUSSION
AND MEMBERS HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON ADAM SO WE WON'T
TAKE THAT UP FOR VOTE.
MEANWHILE, WE HAVE TWO
REMAINING. ISSUES 11 AND 12. I
THINK WHAT WE WILL DO AT THIS
MOMENT BEAR WITH US IS WE'LL
TAKE A BRIEF BRIEF RECESS TO
STRETCH B RECESS. GIVE CENTER
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AN OPPORTUNITY
MAKE OUR WAY BACK, MR CHAIR. YES
IT WAS TESTING THE LIMITS HERE
TELLING YOU, UH AND THEN WE'LL
RECONVENE AND DISPOSE OF THE
FINAL ITEM. SO THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THE COMMITTEE WILL
STAND IN RECESS FOR ABOUT 56
MINUTES.
SUB-COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
AND RECONVENE UNDER ITEMS FOR
DISCUSSION WITH THE NOTED
CHANGES TO THE DOCKET WILL TAKE
UP ISSUES 11 AND 12. AND THEN WE
WILL GO BACK TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT AND TAKE UP ISSUE
NUMBER ONE AS THE DISCUSSION
ITEM SO WITH RESPECT TO ISSUE 11
REDUCTIONS TO THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION OF HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM PLEASE
PROCEED. èC HUXMAN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A 245 $247.5
MILLION REDUCTION FOR THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS, AND THAT
INCLUDES 85 MILLION AND 24, 25
100 MILLION AND 2526 AND 62.5
MILLION IN 2627, THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM PROVIDES
FUNDING TO PURCHASE MULTIFAMILY
PROPERTIES THAT ARE AT RISK OF
FORECLOSE. THE 2021 BUDGET
INCLUDED $500 MILLION IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROGRAM, THE 2023 BUDGET REDUCED
THE PROGRAM BY $15 MILLION TO
$485 MILLION IN DEFERRED 247.5
MILLION THROUGHOUT YEARS. UH
WITH THIS PROPOSAL, 252.5
MILLION GENERAL FUND OR
APPROXIMATELY 50% REMAINS FOR
THIS PROGRAM. L, A GINNY BELLA,
WITH THE ANALYSTS OFFICE. WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THAT 252
MILLION THAT WAS REFERENCED HAS
THAT MONEY HAS NOT YET GONE OUT
EITHER. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ARE THERE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
SUB-COMMITTEE ON ISSUE NUMBER?
11 PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. YOUR
TIME IS LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU. WELCOME. ON WE ARE
REALLY INTERESTED AND WORRIED
ABOUT THE HERE AT THE END OF THE
DAY. I DID SOME TIME TO GET THE
PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING. BUT THIS
IS ANOTHER THING WAY OF
PRESERVING AND ACTUALLY, ADAM.
UM, STOCK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GONNA DO ANY
CONSTRUCTION. WE'RE ACTUALLY
EXIST. IN THE MARKET IN
FORECLOSED AND ADDING, MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE STAYING IN
THE HOUSE, MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ADDING TO OUR STOCK AS
WE'RE LOSING IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, SO WE WOULD ASK THAT
THIS ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY
HINSCHE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK. UM
I'D LIKE TO, UM, OFFER A
STATISTIC ABOUT THE PER UNIT.
UM, COST FOR THE FIP VERSUS NEW
CONSTRUCTION, SO IT'S 276 TO
$480,000 PER UNIT FOR A FIP APP
ACQUISITION, WHEREAS NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS APPROXIMATELY
480,000 TO A MILLION DOLLARS PER
UNIT FOR NEW, UH, THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND SO THIS IS A
LOT MORE BANG FOR YOUR DOLLAR.
UM UNDERSTANDING THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE PROGRAM, AND
IT'S INTENDED EFFECT. AN ARRAY
OF STAKEHOLDERS HAVE DEDICATED
RESOURCES TO PREPARE FOR THE FIP
IMPLEMENTATION. THE TEAM AT HÌ
èC Dð HAS LED THE WAY WORKING
FOR 2.5 YEARS TO STAND UP THE
PROGRAM. PHILANTHROPY AND
NONPROFITS HAVE ALSO BEEN ACTIVE
THROUGHOUT, PROVIDING FEEDBACK
AND PREPARING FOR FUTURE FIT
RECIPIENTS THROUGH THE TRAININGS
, BUSINESS PLANNING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK TO ADDRESS SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. EXACT LIKE WHO
WOULD BE HARMED? UM, WE HAVE 42
NONPROFIT LAND TRUST NETWORK
MEMBERS WHO DEVELOP AND STEWARD
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE COMMUNITY
OWNED HOUSING. OUR MEMBER
ORGANIZATION SPAN CALIFORNIA,
FROM HUMBOLDT COUNTY TO SAN
DIEGO, 80% OF èC L Tð RESIDENTS
ARE BLACK, INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND 60% OF CLT
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE ANNUAL INCOMES
BELOW $40,000. THANK YOU. HELLO,
G TO MAKE THE CLUES FROM THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
THANKS FOR HAVING US, UM IN 2020
THREE 3 34,766 UNI. HOUSE OF
HOMES, INCLUDING 9000/9000
RENTAL UNITS GOT NOTICES OF
DEFAULT THAT WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS FIT FUNDING 100,000 PEOPLE
WILL BE A WILL BE IMPACTED, UM,
BY THESE DEFAULTS, AND THAT'S
100,000 PEOPLE WHO ARE AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS. PHILIP KEEPS
SPECULATORS FROM FROM BUYING UP
THESE HOMES, AND IT KEEPS PEOPLE
HOUSED AND PRESERVES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. UM AS A TOOL TO
MITIGATE OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
, SO WE URGE YOU TO KEEP THE
REMAINING FUNDING OF THE
ORIGINAL $500 MILLION INTACT. WE
URGE YOU TO USE AND SEE THIS AS
A TOOL FOR THE STATE, UM, TO
HAVE IN ITS TOOLBOX TO INCREASE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY, AND WE
URGE YOU TO KEEP THE FUTURE
COMMITMENTS FOR F INTACT AND
FUNDED AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT SEEING NÓ ONE ELSE.
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
SUB-COMMITTEE THE SENATOR. SMALL
BOAS. ONE QUESTION USING THIS
THIS THIS FUNDING FOR F. I, UM,
HOW MANY PROPERTIES ARE THERE
CURRENTLY THAT HAVE BEEN, UM USE
THESE FUNDS TO BE REFURBISHED
AND THEN TURNED INTO HOUSING.
SO THIS FUNDING WAS ALLOCATED
BUT HADN'T THE YOUR AGENCY DID
NOT GET THAT MONEY OUT? YEAH
THERE WAS A SLIGHT DELAY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
DUE TO THE NEED FOR A STATUTORY
CHANGE, WHICH WE RECEIVED LAST
YEAR. AND SINCE THEN WE'VE BEEN
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVEN'T YET ENCUMBERED
THOSE FUNDS INTO A STANDARD
AGREEMENT TO PROVIDER THAT WOULD
OFFER THOSE SERVICES. SO I WOULD
JUST ADD MATT SCHULER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT, UM, THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THE SOLICITATION PROCESS
FOR THE FUND MANAGER, RIGHT?
WE'VE MADE AN AWARD TO THE FUND
MANAGER, BUT WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS, SO WE
HAVEN'T FULLY EXECUTED THE
CONTRACT THAT WOULD THEN MANAGE
THE FUNDING. SO TO MY
COLLEAGUE'S POINT, WE HAVEN'T
STARTED YET, BUT THAT'S
PRECISELY WHERE WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS. I'M JUST BEING NEW TO
THE LEGISLATURE. I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN WERE WHEN WERE
YOU DIRECTED TO? ESTABLISH THIS
FUND AND TO BE ABLE TO, UM,
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM. WHEN
WHEN? WHEN WAS THIS? HOW LONG
HAS THIS DELAY BECAUSE IT FEELS
LIKE NOW WE'VE THE CRISIS OF OUR
BUDGET HAS CAUGHT UP. TO THE
DELAYS. YOU WANNA UM, IT'S I
BELIEVE THIS FUNDING WAS IN 2021
I. I BELIEVE SO. THIS IS FROM
THE 2021 BUDGET. BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
NOTED, THIS IS A PRETTY NEW AND
NOVEL PROGRAM FOR THE STATE. SO
THERE WAS A REQUIREMENTS FROM
BOTH THE YOU KNOW THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND FROM THE STATE
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM
STATUTORILY TO REALLY ALLOW THIS
PROGRAM TO WORK AS INTENDED, AND
SO THOSE CHANGES WERE MADE LAST
YEAR. SO PRIOR TO THAT, I MEAN,
THERE WAS A LOT THERE WAS A LOT
OF WORK HAPPENING, UM, TO TRY TO
UP THE PROGRAM, AND THAT'S WHERE
THESE DIFFERENT NUANCES IN THE
IN THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE, UM
WERE, UM, WERE FLAGGED AND SO WE
WERE ABLE TO ENACT THOSE CHANGES
LAST YEAR WITH THE HELP OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS COMMITTEE.
UM BUT, UM SO AND THE DEPARTMENT
HAS A $252 MILLION, WHICH WAS
NOTED WAS AWARDED TO, UM TO A TO
A FUND MANAGER. AND THEN THIS IS
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD. UH, SO
THERE'S FUNDING. THAT WAS, UM,
PROPOSED TO BE A WAR TO BE
APPROPRIATED IN 24, 25, 25, 26
AND 2627. AND SO THIS PROPOSAL
IS REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TOWARD
THOSE COMMITMENTS AND SAYING WE
CAN'T AFFORD THEM RIGHT NOW. THE
FUND. SO THE CONTRACT THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THAT IS
FUNDED THERE IS TO EXECUTE THIS
NEW RELATIONSHIP WITH THIS FUND
MANAGER TO RELEASE THESE FUNDS
TO THE PROCESS. AND AS THE
AGENDA STATES THERE'S ROUGHLY
$190 MILLION IN GRANTS. THERE'S
A PORTION THAT'S THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COST FOR THE FUND
MANAGER. AND THEN THERE'S A
PORTION THAT STATE OPERATIONS
FOR THE ACTIVITY THAT NEEDS TO
OCCUR AT HÌ èC Dð. OK, THANKS
FOR CLARIFYING THAT. NÓ ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL TAKE UP. THANK YOU.
WE'LL TAKE UP ISSUE 12
ADDITIONAL STAFFING FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND PERMANENT
LOCAL HOUSING ALLOCATION
PROGRAM. PROCEED. BLAIR HUXMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HÌ Tð Dð
REQUESTS FOR POSITIONS IN 2425
AND ONGOING TO MONITOR THE
PERMANENT LOCAL HOUSING
ALLOCATION PROGRAM. DISPERSE
FUNDS AND REPORT UNAFFORDABLE
OWNER OCCUPIED WORK. UH,
WORKFORCE HOUSING OUTCOMES SINCE
THE PERMANENT LOCAL HOUSING
ALLOCATION PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 2020, NEARLY 300
JURISDICTIONS HAVE RECEIVED
THEIR FUNDING ALLOCATIONS,
CREATING A YEAR ROUND NEED FOR
CONTRACT MONITORING
ADMINISTRATION. THERE IS A
POTENTIAL FOR THREE 150
CONTRACTS IN TOTAL, BASED ON THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
JURISDICTIONS, AND THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF CONTRACTS
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO
CONTINUE TO PROPERLY MONITOR THE
PROGRAM. CONCERNS TO RAISE ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE SUB COMMITTEE ON ISSUE
NUMBER 12? ALL RIGHT, UM, LET ME
UH I JUST ONE SEC. JUST TO NOTE
WHAT ISSUE 11 WILL BE HELD OPEN
ISSUE. 12 IS AN INFORMATION ONLY
ITEM. AND WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO WHAT WAS NOTICED AS ISSUE ONE
UNDER. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I APPRECIATE IT. AND WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT. AND TAKE ISSUE ONE
REDUCTION IN COMMUNITY CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AND CONCILIATION
FUNDING. AS AN ITEM FOR
DISCUSSION. WELCOME BACK. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. ADAM ROMERO
WITH THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT. I INVITE, UH,
FINANCE TO PRESENT THIS MATTER.
FLAIR HUXMAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE 2022 BUDGET PROVIDED
THREE YEARS AND LIMITED TERM
GENERAL FUNDING TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND TRAINING TO
COMMUNITIES FACING HATE
INCIDENTS OR OTHER CONFLICT OVER
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
WITHDRAW THE FINAL YEAR OF THE
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING.
UH, PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT FOR COST
SAVINGS OF $883,000 GIVEN THE
CURRENT GENERAL FUND OUTLOOK.
YOU HAVE NOTHING TO ADD. ALL
RIGHT. ADDITIONAL COMMENT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. SURE AS AS
BACKGROUND UM AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE, IN MY COMMENTS, IN
ADDITION TO INVESTIGATING
THOUSANDS OF COMPLAINTS PER YEAR
AND PROSECUTING HIGH IMPACT
CASES ON BEHALF OF LARGE NUMBERS
OF CALIFORNIANS, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SERVICES THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT OFFERS IS FREE
CONCILIATION IN THE FORM OF OUR
INVESTIGATORS, CONCILIATION
CONCILIATING CASES OR IN THE
FORM OF OUR TRAINED MEDIATORS IN
OUR DISPUTE RESOLUTION DIVISION.
CONCILIATING INDIVIDUAL CASES.
WHAT THIS FUNDING DID WAS CREATE
A NEW COMMUNITY CONFLICT
RESOLUTION PROGRAM IN WHICH WE
WERE NOT JUST RESPONDING TO OR
PROVIDING CONCILIATION SERVICES
TO INDIVIDUAL COMPLAINTS, BUT
ACTUALLY GOING OUT INTO
COMMUNITIES AND OFFERING DISPUTE
RESOLUTION SERVICES AND OTHER
TYPES OF CONFLICT RESOLUTION
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCING TENSION AND
CONFLICT AROUND HATE VIOLENCE
AND DISCRIMINATION. IN THE TWO
YEARS OF FUNDING THAT WE HAVE
HAD THIS THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO LAUNCH THIS PROGRAM. WE HIRED
THREE STAFF INTO PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND, UM HAVE IT HAS
BEEN. I THINK VERY SUCCESSFUL.
IT HAS EXCEEDED THE GOALS SET
OUT IN THE B èC P JUST AS A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES WHERE THERE
ARE NUMEROUS EXAMPLES IN THE
AGENDA TODAY THAT I THINK
OUTLINED THE VARIOUS TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT WE'VE OFFERED AS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE. JUST YESTERDAY
, OUR DEPARTMENT PARTNERED WITH
THE L A CITY UH, CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT AND THE
FEDERAL U S¼ ATTORNEY IN THE
CENTRAL DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA
TO HOST A PROGRAM FOR RELIGIOUS
LEADERS IN LOS ANGELES, AROUND
BUILDING BRIDGES AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE AT THE STATE, LOCAL
AND FEDERAL LEVEL AVAILABLE TO
RELIGIOUS LEADERS WHO ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THEIR CONGREGANTS
COMING TO THEM FACING
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
SO WE, UM, HAD A TERRIF. EVENT
YESTERDAY, AND THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE TYPE OF PROGRAM
THAT THAT THIS, UM UNIT IS
OFFERING OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF
THE BUDGET SHORTFALLS THIS YEAR.
UM THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO WITHDRAW THIS
FUNDING. HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT
WILL INTEND TO USE SAVINGS FROM
OTHER PLACES TO KEEP THIS THESE
THREE POSITIONS. UH UH, GOING
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE SUBCOMITTEE. SENATOR
SMALL CUEVAS. I'M I'M CURIOUS. I
SEE THAT THIS THIS MONEY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS RECOMMENDING
THAT THIS MONEY BE PULLED BACK.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT SEEMS TO
BE WORKING. I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT YOU HAVE. UM
AND I WANT TO POINT OUT, UM, A
STUDY BY U èC L, A UM, THAT
TALKED ABOUT AND LOOKED AT, UM,
FOR EXAMPLE, UM, THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S BUREAU OF FIELD
ENFORCEMENT AND THROUGH THAT
MODEL, THEY HAVE, UM IDENTIFIED
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS, UM,
THAT WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO
BUILD HIGH QUALITY IN DEPTH
INVESTIGATIVE CAPACITY AND
PARTNERSHIP TO ADDRESS, UM,
ISSUES THAT FACE UM, UH,
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN THE
WORKFORCE. AND IT MAKES ME SORT
OF ASK THE QUESTION, ESPECIALLY
AS MORE OF THE STATE INVESTMENT
AND THE KINDS OF PROGRAMS THAT
YOU YOU MENTIONED IS GOING TO BE
DECLINING BY THIS. THIS PROPOSAL
HAS èC R Dð CONSIDERED ADOPTING
A SO A SIMILAR STRATEGIC
ENFORCEMENT MODEL WHERE YOU ARE,
UM INCREASING CAPACITY AND ALSO
LEVERAGING RESOURCES, BOTH AT
THE CITY LEVEL, THE COUNTY LEVEL
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. YOU
GAVE THAT WHICH IS GREAT TO DO
EVENTS. UM BUT WHEN YOU DO
STRATEGIC SORT OF PARTNERSHIPS
FOR ENFORCEMENT, THERE'S A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITY TO MAXIMIZE, UM,
INVESTMENT. SO COULD YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE PARTNERSHIPS
AND WHAT WAYS AND WHAT YOU MIGHT
NEED FROM US TO BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE MORE OUT OF THESE
PARTNERSHIPS? HAVING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
GROUPS, PARTNERSHIPS WITH
RELIGIOUS LEADERS, PARTNERSHIPS
WITH CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE. ALL
OF THESE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US TO INCREASE OUR CAPACITY AND
ONE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH YOU DO
THAT IS THROUGH OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION. AND THOSE AREN'T JUST
ONE OFF EVENTS BUT OUR
STRATEGICALLY PLANNED IN WHICH
WE WORK WITH DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
GROUPS OR OTHER TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT I MENTIONED
AS WELL AS LOCAL AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL BECAUSE
THERE'S AN INTERPLAY OF THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND THE
SERVICES THAT THEY CAN OFFER,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
THAT WORK BECAUSE I THINK THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN WE NEED TO
REDUCE, UH THE SILOS AND REDUCE
THE BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
SERVICES. SO WE COME TOGETHER TO
WITH THESE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
AND COMMUNITY GROUPS IN ORDER TO
STRATEGICALLY PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS ABOUT
THE SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM AND HOW WE CAN BE
HELPFUL. AND I APPRECIATE
INFORMATION. UM, I GUESS WHAT
THE PROPOSED CUTS WOULD DO
AFFECT OUR BACKLOG. IT WOULD
AFFECT OUR DELAYS. AND SO IT'S
MORE THAN INFORMATION IN TERMS
OF WHAT CONCRETE CAPACITY THAT
CAN HELP THE STATE. BETTER UM,
UM, ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THESE
PROTECTED CLASSES THAT THAT RELY
ON US FOR ENFORCEMENT. SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE IS IN A MORE
SORT OF STRATEGIC COLLABORATION
TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT WAYS TO
REDUCE BACKLOGS AND TO REDUCE
THE KINDS OF ENFORCEMENT UM,
BARRIERS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
STATE WHICH ARE GOING TO BE
EXACERBATED NOW THAT WE ARE NOW
CUTTING MORE AND MORE OF THE
BUDGET, SO III I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT WAYS
IN WHICH THERE IS, UM THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE AND CAN BE
LEVERAGED TO HELP THE STATE
ADDRESS ITS BACKLOG. AND I'M
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED BECAUSE
AS YOU KNOW, WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF HAVING AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS. COME IN THE STATE FOR
OUR CLIMATE, RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. UM, WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE, YOU KNOW
THE NUMBER ONE HISTORY AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS WHO'S EXCLUDED
FROM ACTUALLY DOING THAT WORK
AND èC R Dð IS GOING TO BE
CALLED ON TO ENSURE THAT AS
WE'RE INVESTING FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT WOMEN WORKERS OF COLOR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS, UM HAVE A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE ACCESS. I
MEAN, WE'RE AND I THINK YOU
KNOW, WE CRD NEEDS TO THINK LONG
AND HARD AROUND. HOW DO WE
LEVERAGE PARTNERSHIPS TO HELP US
BUILD CAPACITY AND WHAT ARE THE
WAYS THAT THE STATE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MEET THIS MOMENT OF
HAVING TO PROTECT MORE CLASSES?
BUT ALSO THIS UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY THAT HAS TO BE A
MULTIPLIER IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE LONG BEEN EXCLUDED? UM
FROM FROM THIS THIS SECTOR, SO
YOU KNOW, DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
WHAT? èC R Dð S¼ PLAN IS TO
UTILIZE SOME OF THIS FEDERAL
FUNDING TO STRENGTHEN YOUR
ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY AND ABILITY
TO REALLY TRACK MONITOR AND
ENSURE, UM, FAIR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED IS IN THE
FORM OF REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE U
S¼ EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION AND THE U S¼
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT WHEN THERE IS A DUAL
FILED CASE THAT COULD BE FILED
IN THE FEDERAL VENUE OR IN WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT IF WE INVESTIGATE
THAT FEDERAL AGENCIES PROVIDE US
A PARTIAL REIMBURSEMENT OF OUR
COSTS FOR INVESTIGATING THOSE
CASES. SO THOSE ARE THE
MECHANISMS IN WHICH WE OBTAIN
FEDERAL FUNDING. WE'VE ALSO
RECEIVED A GRANT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, UH, TO
SUPPORT OUR CALIFORNIA VERSUS
HATE PROGRAM. WE APPLIED FOR THE
JAR HIGHER GRANT AND RECEIVED IT
. UM I'M NOT AWARE OF OTHER
FUNDING FEDERAL FUNDING THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO OUR DEPARTMENT. BUT
I'M CERTAINLY WOULD WELCOME
LEARNING ABOUT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. UH, FROM YEAH, I.
I AND I APPRECIATE THAT. I KNOW
THAT THROUGH, UM, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS AROUND
THE GOOD JOBS INITIATIVE. UM
AROUND, YOU KNOW, CREATING ITS
EQUITY. UM, EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
PARTNERSHIPS IN THE HIGHER
PROGRAM AT THE EEOC THAT THERE
IS AN EMPHASIS ON MAKING SURE
THERE'S ANTI DISCRIMINATION
PROTECTIONS WITHIN THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT IS COMING TO THE
STATE AND THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
LEVERAGE TO ENSURE GOOD JOBS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. LOCAL COUNTY STATE
, UM, THAT WE CAN WORK TO
LEVERAGE THOSE FUNDS AND IN THIS
MOMENT, MAKE SURE èC R Dð IS
PREPARED TO MEET THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE. SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING WHAT OTHER FUNDING
STREAMS MIGHT BE AVAILABLE AS
THE ADMINISTRATION. THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING THESE
CUTS. THANK YOU. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. I
WOULD ONLY JUST ADD THAT, UM,
OUR DEPARTMENT ENFORCES. THE
RULES THAT APPLY
NON-DISCRIMINATION IN STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES
AS WELL AS TO STATE CONTRACTORS.
AND SO WE DO RECEIVE COMPLAINTS
UNDER THOSE PROVISIONS AND DO
INVESTIGATE THEM AND TAKE OTHER
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS AS
NECESSARY. YEAH AND THAT'S WHAT
POTENTIAL OF 100 AND 14 BILLION
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO COME INTO
THAT PROGRAM. WE'VE GOT TO SCALE
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
MONITOR TO ENSURE AGAIN. THIS
SORT OF INSTITUTIONAL AND
HISTORIC EXCLUSION IS NOT
HAPPENING IN THIS NEW CLIMATE,
RESILIENCE SPACE, SO I THINK
IT'S UM, MEETING THE MOMENT AND
REQUIRES US TO LOOK MORE DEEPLY
AND TO THINK ABOUT THE STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN, PARTICULARLY IN
THIS DEFICIT. UM, TIME, SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR WORK AND
FOR WORKING WITH US ON MOVING
THIS TO A MORE DEEPER
DISCUSSION. THAT ITEM WILL ALSO
BE HELD. WE'LL MOVE BACK TO THE
ITEMS FOR VOTE ONLY, WHICH IS
ONLY ISSUE NUMBER TWO UNDER HÌ
èC Dð, WHICH IS ADDITIONAL
STAFFING TO ADMINISTER FEDERAL
FUNDED PROGRAMS. AND I'LL
ENTERTAIN EMOTION. SO ALL RIGHT
MOTION IS TO APPROVE HIS
BUDGETED THERE ANY CONVERSATION
FROM THE SUBCOMITTEE? NON
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOST IS APPRO APPROVE ITEM
ONE AS BUDGETED SENATOR PADILLA
SENATOR SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. ALL RIGHT. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE, THANKS TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY IN THE
HEARING MORE WORK TO BE DONE AT
THIS TIME. THE SUB COMMITTEE
BUDGET SUB NUMBER FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION.